[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
can you you
amazing on
[Music]
your
w
[Music]
yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah
you
[Music]
yeah
am
[Music]
yeah
I
[Music]
we
you
[Music]
down
yes
[Music]
d
yes
[Music]
w
yes
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
a
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
d
he
[Music]
n
w
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
you
St with the counter his jab incredible
performance oh I love this guy back to
back I see you n oh my God
give it up for your
Champion is this not some good ass teken
ladies and
[Applause]
[Music]
gentlemen therefore evil 2021 and we got
to see a super sick finals with two
different regions with Central and South
and a lot of these players are back too
we got Seri back we have Bell back and
man we have some other killers in this
bracket today too we have a a I believe
a master Raven player by the name of
crew he's going to be going up against
sergy later in the bracket as well and
uh yeah Ricky's been telling me that
that we have a Steve in our Miss for uh
the top eight so I'm very excited I'm
very excited for that yeah I'm I'm I'm a
little worried about how it's going to
happen right because there's a lot of
lot of great Killers out there you know
we know the South America scene is like
super strong right so this is like one
of the one of the crazier ones out there
especially considering that you know
some of the favorites that we've seen
have been upset so far you know Zury we
just saw one Evo South America right
he's in the loser bracket so you know
there can be some upsets but even the
person that put him to the losers
bracket is in the losers bracket so you
know it's like disgusting
one of those things man so it's a tough
one but man South America they always
bring the heat you know they always
bring the good good ass Tech in here so
you know I'm excited to see what they
got to offer because you know we're
mashima fans right but we're not Mishima
Mains but we know that they got the
mashima down here so you know I'm I'm
excited I can't wait to see exactly I
think uh even even that match as well uh
it was a Kazan there but yeah once again
big shout out to our family over there
at Astro the official headset and the
MixAmp of the Tekken online challenge
here 2021 big shout once again holding
it down for many events here at the fgc
we know I'm and love them man supporting
us here icfc many other
tournaments yeah and then we can see the
leaderboard here for South America you
see Abel Deo he's also in the winners
today so we will see him later today uh
first place there Jackson 5 Second Noel
Tojo rounding out the top four and then
fifth Sergey matser six Pito seventh
Alonso Gonzalez and eth Leo ZZ so you
see a lot of representation from Peru
there but you got some you got some
Chilla you got some Bolivia and you also
got Brazil at the end there and look at
me learning learning Flags man I know
I'm learning because you're telling
me the education's working but yeah I'm
super excited to see These Guys these
are the number one uh these are the top
eight players right now in the points
these guys are all duking it out this is
the Master Level event the most amount
of points you get at online Challenge
and these guys are duking it out for
those I definitely can't wait to see I
mean we are familiar with a lot of these
names we saw Abel he has that really
Godlike Eliza and Eddie Gordo and uh
even players like Leo ZZ we haven't seen
in a minute as well like I've been
seeing some of his master Raven Tech
online it's been looking really nice
yeah I mean you know these guys been
playing for so long you know we've seen
them now for over the past like five
years you know like we've seen that
these guys have been improving and
getting better as a region and to be
able to just see them play online you
know get to see them kind of in their
element right because usually we get a
sneak prak every every year we would
just go there we would see him once and
that be like all right we'll see you
guys next year right but see now we get
to see them online you get to see how
they're progressing and just seeing like
their aggressive style and their their
unique play style online as well as
offline is cool man because you know
they definitely you I'll say this about
South American Tech it's not necessarily
like disrespectful in a way but you feel
disrespected because because the way
they beat you it's like oh I know what
you're going to do and so normally you
know I would play safe and no I'm going
to do the the the hardest read and make
sure you know that I knew exactly what
you were going to do D send a
message dude you sit there sometimes
you're like
oh yeah yeah it's true you can't do
anything but be impressed you're just
like all right yeah I give it up you
know like you got beat up but they also
have to same time it's like you can't
get too hung up on that one thing they
did exactly yeah but it's at the same
time it's like they just hit me with the
dirtiest thing in the world and they're
playing Super solo Tekken what am I
supposed to do about this I mean you
know some people I think you know some
people let's be honest right the online
culture nowadays where it's like if you
key charge oh uhoh uh-uh no right you
got
thech of TW against you yeah I've been
see a bunch of tweets now it's like it's
Blasphemous to do like a corpse body
hits or whatever and I'm like man these
are things that have been around forever
I mean they if if you got mad at every
time someone key charg and ab Bel Dem
Maestro would just be like the biggest
villain of the all time right cuz he key
charges whenever he gets happy you know
he gets pumped up it's like a I won this
round you know I got got a key charge
get myself amped up m i I feel like key
charging me so many different things in
different uh regions as well but you
know a lot of times in na we look at it
as like a taunt or something but people
have been doing key charges as like a
post round popup for forever you
know man but I'm excited to see how this
plays out too especially because you
know the characters are going to be so
different right and so you know like
we're excited for Steve but I want to
see what Steve is like you know from
from South America I want to see what
Max is like you know we already know
what kazuya is like it's crazy so it's
like I want to see what what all these
other characters they got have and you
know just looking at the the the
brackets and the standings right now we
know that they do have like a different
you a handful of different characters
that are top tier but their best player
AB Bela Maestro that's you know the most
consistent Eddie and Eliza always the
weirdest combination of that is a very
strange combination and then you also
have uh like players like sapito right
is a l Ling specialist as well it's like
in a land full of Mishima like sometimes
like The Oddities of like the noral
Tekken characters feel like okay all
right I want to see those uh the weird
ones you know like we got a couple Raven
players as well with uh crew
along with Leo AZ so yeah they're woo
and also the Mishima matchups
potentially oh I can't wait I can't wait
the machima in South America oh and we
got a match here I believe these are top
eight qualifiers so these aren't
actually top eight yet these are going
to be the loser side winner of this will
make top eight loser goes home and here
we got Parker versus Jackson 5 I believe
this is La Parov uh Lars though not the
most uh used character but one of us is
a fan here and look at that I dude you
already know man I love them oh wow look
at these stage transition what what the
I never noticed the slope on that oh man
it's like a rumble in the Bronx or
something like I want to just like send
Jackie
Channel top
of wow Lars versus Negan here we go I
don't care about this this is all you
this is this is all me I'm smiling right
now I'm smiling down forward one two
intimidation went for the plus frames
afterwards as well wow they're swinging
Arc blast gets punished oh man Jackson 5
swinging there though look at all this
wall pressure just a bunch of barrage of
down forward ones down forward four
threes mids and lows coming out of
Jackson 5 L parka doesn't know where to
defend yeah he gets on Le Parker he
wanted to to attack but Jackson was just
constantly down for one down for one you
just staying in his face mhm didn't let
him off the wall either what an initiate
to a teeking God pro oh my goodness
guess the side step launcher breaking
the side wall oh yeah probably didn't
recognize if that wasn't even going to
be a sidewall like that either Mony
scenario
there here oh was just a bunch of jab
down for one strings sprinkled in La
parka in trouble fight
Jackson Five with so much momentum man
it's so unfortunate too because right
now it's like the par on this stage too
lar seems to be decent on the stage but
just hasn't got anything going he's he's
had his back against the wall oh my God
God
immediately immediately okay took the
risk oh but he flipped over on the down
back 2 one because it was off axis super
unfortunate for La parka there and he's
not going to be able to even get the
round
wow Jackson Five man the beat down so
fast too was like every time Le Parker
had any sort of offense a drop and it
was immediately responded to a launch
was like oh that sucks dude cuz you you
thought you had it you thought you had
the the the guaranteed combo that's the
reason why you did that that's the
reason why you thought it was going to
hit and turns out because you did that
you lost you know those are the worst oh
man but you know Jackson f was just so
aggressive the entire time Le parka it
seemed like every time he got anything
even going his back was already at the
wall you know super small stage the
helicore uh helipad right there and
especially before the walls got broken
and especially the angle that they were
ended up being at it always turn into a
sidewall break or something you know so
the conversion got a little funky but
yeah good stuff to Jackson 5 there Negan
still looking strong I mean his Negan
we've seen his Negan Al also right we
saw it that the the evil qualifi as well
so you know he's his a NE might be the
main character now you know we cuz you
know Jackson 5 was mainly a jack player
but as far as I've seen you know it's
only been Negan and the Negan looks good
I mean that what the knife from downtown
he just CAU him out nothing yeah he just
caught him going directly into dynamic
entry stands which is LS 4ward three
also closes the distance but the way he
threw that out with such confidence and
to and that's not even like a safe move
to throw out safe it's not this doesn't
really lead to much damage I mean you
get guaranteed stuff afterwards but it's
not necessarily like your you know it's
not a orbital you know the the the the
risk reward there isn't necessarily in
your favor but I think that's that's
kind of the play style of South America
and you know they're more willing to
make hard reach cuz they know it's going
to work but oh we see the Fang coming
out here Parker with the
Fang okay we're going to be moving over
to the Hammerhead stage as well that is
the rules if you get if you guys switch
to characters you guys have to go random
select or you could pick the same
character and go for a stage
select interesting setup here between
the two players oh my goodness intros
that they just took this from the actual
game I didn't even know that wow look at
all the little details in the background
I didn't even know there was another
trailer back
there oh wow that's the jackpot uh yeah
Jack seven freaking down forward two
right there translated over to the Negan
oh the fan coming out swing back kle was
still able to block in time yeah
lucky nice back kimple just to create
space dashing to get the whip punish
with the
Jabs wall
pressure doesn't try to duck or
anything Parker with a small lead here
oh there went dang that was unfortunate
he kind of defaulted into a one two into
a down back three Jackson Five just beat
him out of
[Music]
it here comes the down forward one
intimidation pressure again you ain't
going nowhere is ridiculous right now
where Jackson 5 is just like L parka
feels like he has some sort of momentum
and then like jackon takes it and then
takes the next round with it too it's
like your momentum from one round gives
me two right and this is Le Parker is in
so much trouble he had a lot of good
momentum here but Jackson 5 as soon as
he's in trouble he finds that magical
down forward to and he brings it all the
way back big lead here for La parka nice
punish keeps I want to utilize that c
that back Campo step a little bit more I
mean it's been paying off but he hasn't
been reacting quick enough oh here we go
Jabs and down forward one pressure oh
all day finds a down back three uses the
rage immediately looking for a wall
Splat but the low plus plus
plus this is this is real rough for Le
parka and that's it Jackson Five takes
it my God
G she is a vampire dang textbook Negan
play there by Jackson 5 uh a lot of dep
pestering with the down forward ones and
the jab strings really got to S uh not
SED yeah yeah right there because every
time every time he went like L parka was
getting pestered by the down for ones
and the lows and then he would kind of
like go for like Panic one tws and then
not see if it hit or not and then
immediately go for down back threes and
Jackson 5 were calling those out with
like immediate down forward twos counter
hitting those so great play there to
Jackson Five yeah I mean it's easy to
tell the Jackson Five as soon as he
started getting any offense he was like
it's I got to keep going you know and
negan's the one of the stronger
characters do that if you let him do
those back OnePlus tws or you know out
of the strings one two OnePlus tws it's
like all right Negan will take that like
all right look I like being plus a
million I'm going to keep the pressure
up right and I just felt like Jackson
was just in his element you know he felt
so comfortable with his offense you know
just keeping the flow the flow of
offense going right so as soon as he
blocked one plus back one plus two then
was like all right now we begin you know
now you're going to see my down forward
ones come out more the lows and so that
pretty much open them open them all up
and yeah nice job from Jackson so he's
going to make it to the top eight this
time so good showing from him
unfortunately for Le par eliminated in
ninth place we all know that feeling it
sucks Ninth Place at a major ter it
always just feels so cuz it's like
eighth place is like the pedestal right
like if you make it into the top eight
at least you could be happy that hey I'm
made it into the top eight got some
points you know it's like it feels like
Ninth Place to eighth place the Gap is
like you know it's I mean you know it's
obvious it's it's it's made that way
because we you know idolize top eight
right know like good good good words
right top eight right but it just
depends on where it is you know cuz
sometimes sometimes top eight feels like
top four because you get fifth place
you're like damn man I missed the money
it's like oh yeah yeah fifth place don't
feel that good no more does it yeah
that's that's always been the popular
one in my opinion Ninth Place at a major
or fourth place at a
local fourth place at a local doesn't
feel bad but fourth place when you're
out of the money anywhere feels bad yeah
yeah exactly fourth place at a local
doesn't feel too bad even if it's like
not that much money but it's like it
still feels bad yeah yeah oh man I think
Anakin put it in a great point for be
like at combo breakers that year he was
like you know what everybody cuz I was
sad that I was out of the tournament he
was just like bro everybody feels that
way except for the guy that won the
whole thing and I was like no one feels
happy even even if even if they like
even if they like get like you know like
third place you know they did really
well right but it's like when you're in
third place you made the money you're
but you still feel like you still you
still feel
terrible it's just like I know I could
have done better I could yeah I know
that feel I know it's tough man that's
that's tournaments though man that is
tournaments and I mean you know these
players they can tell you themselves
these you know these players that we're
going to be watching today they've all
been here and you know the thing funny
thing is that they've all played each
other right this is not like a uh you
know a big like International Tournament
you know a lot of these guys are
familiar with each other's play Styles
so we're going to see a lot more like
interesting like why'd he do that you
know like even bigger call outs bigger
reads and all that it's like dude you
always do that there why wouldn't I yeah
exactly I love those moments and it's
like one of those things we it's likeing
it doesn't make sense to people that
aren't in their shoes right like even
like even if you're like a top player
right you might watching like wow that
was weird right but it makes sense for
them because they they're they're in it
you know they understand that this will
work here in this situation so you know
that's the that's the beauty about
playing in tournaments against uh
certain players especially like your own
like local community is that like you
just you keep building that that sort of
uh you know recipe of just like success
and failure right it's just like a gross
recipe that ends up you know you end up
finding success eventually but you need
it needs to look gross at a certain
point no that's H that's honestly the
main saying right that people have been
saying for the longest time you're only
as good as the competition around you
and like if you keep if you you can
consistently be winning the most but as
long as there's people to challenge you
that's how you guys keep getting better
uh you know keep getting stronger too
day by day and that's honestly the best
part and these guys have been duping It
Out by day and here we go into the next
match we have la la madita coming back
versus Avalon okay and griu for ricka
he's got to be so happy we had a legend
by the name of Joe King here in SoCal
but this is Joseph King playing the gy
let's go oh my
heart so happy G is so rare
never you know honestly I think G is a
great tournament character and I think
you see I we see him a lot more than you
know other characters so it's not like I
don't think he's such a rare character I
think the one thing about him though is
that he's just not a popular character
you know but in tournament players that
play in tournaments they understand that
he is a strong character very simple so
it's very easy to be successful with him
in tournament you just have to you know
enjoy playing a fat guy and I enjoy
playing a fat guy so or appreciate the
Arts of sumo all that good good you know
gny is still a lot of fun G is still a
lot of fun and his core tool set has
still been pretty much the same since
Tekken five
so a a I wanted to keep watching that
it looked like the outside of a major
you cuz I you saw that like that weird
little truck outside that weird
tournament in this hagger
okay that's a old that's a old
local yeah it is
honestly yeah we be I I hope we can get
that set up though I'm I'm excited for
some Gan but you know I'm I'm I'm a
sucker for gam we got a little bit of
the teaser right there we got all
excited and then a dang who's going to
be grabbing who you know I wish gadw had
more of those like you know you know how
he had Tai one plus two that's like a
new thing that they gave him and then
that's like the only one that that gives
him the launcher throw now I think that
used to be an option out of all of this
counter hit hug things right he used to
have six options and then he only has it
out of hug in Ford for two now ah dang
down one plus two is a different one
yeah yeah down one plus two is a who's
going to be grappling who more you know
honestly be Muk Marduk will always be
grappling more than ganry because ganry
doesn't have any throws oh there we go
we're going into it that would have been
so sick if they gave up like his own
mini BTS tackle oh my goodness though it
doesn't make any sense for him to have a
tackle though that'd be so sick it'd be
so
sick wow the two1 into the Taiwan trades
whoa oh he Ducks the high
I don't think that was worth it but that
was cool though oh back two one got to
be careful with those back two ones
though especially against players that
know that it it is not like a true like
block string you can't interrupt it in
the middle so by interrupt I mean if you
have a character that can Parry like AA
man just destroying them right now just
out of the gate swinging one throw Oki
side rolls into the spring kick to get
him out of
trouble oh bad spring kick there from uh
Joseph King
[Music]
I do like the pressure though lot of
back two ones though I'd be a little
nice I do like
that the sidewall coming into play but
the full Crouch one plus two wow side
wall
positioning
gosh oh plus three wow size the power
Crush okay goes for the W
car what I'm seeing here takes a plus
frames but he trades with the w sing W
nice back dash to get the get the W nice
yeah just out of range too got the down
forward two to hit fight Joseph King on
the board
now these two really just swinging at
each other I love it I love
this the pressure
City oh the my my G my G juices are are
are fulling a little bit I'm I'm I'm I'm
recognizing I want to say stuff but it's
like
know oh the whole thing okay gets the
443 doubles it up for the plus frame I
like that Ford one attempt wow he went
for it didn't get launched though for it
break on the bts2
throw oh man it it was just about to
turn around there for Joseph King he was
just starting to get some things going
too but man those you know Marduk does
have a true throw game
yeah I mean M is mik is hella good
obviously right I I'm not going to say
that Gan is not hella good in that that
match in my mind that match is pretty
pretty fair but uh you got to be you
know it's it's one of those things where
when Marik hits you his offense keeps
going right and the thing is that you
always got to be worried about the
tackle you always have to have that in
the back of your mind and the thing is
that he dealt with tackle very well he a
lot of them on clutch tackles too yeah
but the fortunate thing is that he got
hit by a lot of mixups right the full
Crouch like the Mix-Ups with the a
headbutt I head scoop I guess I don't
even know what the hell you call that
right yeah it's so good safe and and
then also the fact that they beefed up
the hit box on it now that it truly hits
grounded it never used to hit grounded
before if you don't move it only used to
hit you if you moved but now that it
does that it just opens up so much more
for Mar right because he has he has so
many options because if you're knocked
down and you're not trying to get thrown
you're susceptible to getting ground
throw one or two or he could run the
50/50 from uh Valley toodle dance which
is the head sco or the python explosion
both of those hit grounded even the
three from that position mid launcher
also hits grounded and does the flip
over Marduk is a disgusting character
when it comes to
okazi yeah not that too right like he
still has Tech traps as well with his
like tackle and things like that you got
to just always always be be be aware
right especially cuz he has so many
things in to put you in weird situations
like fighting in front of a bunch of
weirdos like this in in a Dusky Forest
where are we what part of the Earth are
we in I don't even know if this is even
the same universe right if if they have
zombies in the Tekken world then where
does everything else fit into place but
I don't know here we go Gand chucking
away hats G is an exorcist a zombie
Exorcist he's that's the reason why he's
wearing the cape what that was sick you
never see a back one what I mean you see
it you just never see it hit
right oh man course looking forward to
into the Homing move Mar so so strong so
many power moves right now I do like
that though the random the random tie
stance into the uh into the slide yep
very very good that's like my favorite
thing to do again wow the call out on
the duck after the clap you know that is
a very common setup but the fact that
did it so confidently he just called out
like
that wow immediately challenges
disrespects the frame double layered oi
he's like oh I want you to try to whip
punish the first one but nice guess the
whip punish on the python explosion
going to get some damage here the block
punish as well could have let that rock
but it was a little worried oh and he's
going for full mixes oh that's that's
risky full scar wow wow finish does
it uhoh D he did that so fast from oh my
God this is the Oki we're talking about
you're so scared to get up you're so
scared to Tech roll because of tackle
and everything else that man the python
explosion both hits connected there too
with that little sidewall
scenario Joseph King not out of this yet
but definitely looking a little
rough he's going to have to fight out
this corner
too this good start though
step on him you ain't going nowhere I
don't even care if I have a 12 frame jab
I'm swinging them in your face
you wow look at that break again that's
a hard break really on point yeah that's
like two frame break the look forward to
doubles it up though look at the damage
already I love that sequence that
forward two oh you saw that all the L
away just in case the threat of the move
nice grab there throw break though from
the pressure he was expecting to stay
down get to St with the mid didn't duck
that string back to one the call outs
the call outs from both sides Joseph
King brings it back that ties it up here
very
close oh this time gets floated oh no
Val tole throws and the okazi afterwards
oh but this time he crouched for it made
it harder to break himself yeah didn't
break that one oh
no
disgusting bro
disgusting advances into the top with
the Muk man that character is nice dude
I mean yeah when you get when you can
play like that and feel confident in all
your decisions right but I mean the one
thing I noticed is that he was
challenging a lot of challenges right a
lot of those down four threes again you
hit you know he is plus five it's a huge
plus but you know sometimes you got to
be willing to challenge it right and
that's what and that's what he did he
challenged a lot W1 got a counter hit
the majority of the times too so you
know he was willing to take those risks
cuz he knew that they were going to pay
off more often than not and you know
that's the reason why he's he Advanced
to the to the top eight there so nice
job Joseph King was definitely putting
some stuff together but man not enough
not enough but all right we're going to
go ahead and take a look at some of the
rest of the stuff coming up for the
Tekken online challenge we are currently
doing South America right now but as you
guys can see we're going to be moving
over to the West Europe region after
this uh tomorrow and then we're going to
be going into east Europe and then the
rest of the world as you guys can see
right there online Masters events and
then on the right side you guys can
catch the regional finals events and
then accordingly uh you know of course
different dates all throughout so make
sure you guys write down the dates to
see which reasons you guys want to check
out yeah it's going to be sick man I'm
I'm excited just to see what some other
like you know there's some regions in
there that like we don't know too much
about like I'm what's the West Africa
can see like I'm trying to figure that
out man I want to see what's going on
man it's cool it's cool to just to see
that you know over the the growth of
Tekken 7 and the growth of Tekken in
general that we've seen so many
different regions you know kind of stand
up right and like obviously Pakistan uh
Peru we're watching the Philippines but
you know even now it's like I'm sure
even now that we've seen the growth of
this game even more that there's still
little pockets of communities that we
still don't know about I'm sure of it
yes I'm I'm I'm waiting I'm waiting I'm
feing for the next hidden you know
talent pool of players that we just
never even thought of is this is this
one of them though we got Gillard
Gallard with the F with the Evo champ
Seri himself sery in the losers bracket
but the Evo
Champion I am excited for this one let's
go oh and in Suk as well man and you
know this is something we never seen
with South Americas right how do they
deal how do they deal with the New Deal
DC
characters I've never even seen them
play fuer mom or against them yeah I'm
very
excited but Bergie man his Kaza is so
nice to watch and especially when he
starts getting confident he starts
getting looser with the wave Dash man
you're going to see it you guys if you
guys haven't seen Seri kazuya get ready
you're in for a treat
fight yeah he got him so scared already
did he just walk here 112 there yep the
hell oh the angles are just right oh
side one on accident I think he trying
to get one plus two or
something oh there we go
nice I like the pressure oh got counter
wow try to carry to the wall oh almost
look at the damage I already did a
ton nice I like Patience by sery yeah he
saw that the quick rise was happening
and he just blocked it and then took his
turn beautiful crou stash windy and
that's the signs of a real real Mima
yeah you don't need to always go for
electric man sometimes you need the long
windy oh he's in his head he's in his
and big character combo is that a smash
wall combo he did raw tackle too yeah I
know I love it oh my God y sery looking
so strong right now he's like I don't
even yeah you guys thought DLC was a
problem I don't even worry about
DLC I mean yeah right now it doesn't
look he's worrying too much oh counter
it down forward one almost had a respot
with
that all the variation all the
variations he let sery out though this
is bad news and his back is against the
wall back one gets punished yeah this is
how basically the same exact spot he's
lost every round in this
corner had the wall didn't believe and
it got there kind of low too dang Crouch
Dash low sery three rounds straight over
and and sergey's uh offense at the end
there was so nice too cuz it was
pressured but delayed at the same time
right hit him with the four and four and
this like kind of got him to think like
oh I'm I'm I got to stay blocking right
and then he does a little string kind of
delays the little string and then he
goes for another maybe plus and then he
goes for the low like though that kind
of string right there he knew that like
I can I can play safe I don't have to
throw out big RIS I don't have to go for
a hell sweep here for the win I can just
play it slow utilize my frames and my
patience and like right there at that
end there so good so good you know I I I
really love the instances of like the
long windy for the on the three plus
four right the another and the the last
hit at the end too it was like forward
four on block I'm advantaged but I'm not
going to take my frames immediately he
did like a long Crouch Dash into full
Crouch slow probably threw off his low
par timing or when he was expecting the
the low poke or the mid poke to happen
so sery just like a real master of
setting the pace and really setting the
pace and then throwing a wrench in that
pace too at any moment at any moment
love to see that yeah it's he's
basically okay this this is the speed
we're running yet and it's like and
finally went to their opponent like okay
I understand the speed now now s is like
all right now now run run on these TS
real quick check this out it's funny too
that you mentioned the the Wendy's right
being a sign of a true Mishima player
because you know we're scrubs right so
when we see bisha players do Wy we're
like uh this guy sucks
ourish when we do a windy we totally
suck but like when nishima Mains do a
windy damn they're godl cuz cuz they're
hitting it on purpose they're like
they're doing it when we do Wendy's
we're trying to do electrics right
exactly exactly when Mar Bima players do
Wendy's they they were like we don't
need the electri we just need the win
you're right I need the long Crouch and
the win oh damn you see kazuya came up
with the jacket here he knew we were
fighting out in the cold dude that's
exactly
what could have Tech R he could have
tech roled there but the fact that he
launched put his F on back one with an
electric
oh
bro oh what in the
world okay tur is another Beast Man you
guys see
that
Jesus that was literally the
second look at
the one one two
two back I never knew that was a combo
what is going on is too strong okay it
back what I love that love that that was
sick actually showing me some fom tech
too he he I mean he's probably like all
right look I've seen this before no big
deal okay now the fake out into the look
no good punish and got the grounded hit
rage Drive devil form activated oh big
head you're a big boy eat this I've
legit never seen that hit anyone ever
especially grounded right what the hell
oh and he tried it there too are you
serious he got the jet kick though are
you sure they're playing online dude
he's getting perfect electric but he's
trying to do the hardest punish his On
this man's this man's a monster this guy
is a monster oo but fuam is still fak y
gallar gets the round nicely done no
either G has been playing real well too
but it's just man this time he said I'm
done with these strings I'm going to
Magic for it great challenge by Seri
there finish the whole thing oh not the
punish the jab punish he could have got
the launch's going for the 14 launcher
theep launch there that just is going to
be his style he's always going to go
14 nice wall oh my God look at the
damage but the TR and he picks it up big
opportunity wow spend it though stays
Dees to activate this is huge and that's
why that was beautiful
oh oh my gosh man Sergi's ability to
just get an electric when you need it
right is crazy crazy it was so simple
right he dashed up and stopped pumped
the brakes immediately that's when [__]
did a jet kick and it just whiffed right
here legit right in front of his face he
saw that foot and he's like bomb he's
like okay electric everybody here in the
chat you and me the same too every time
we see a whiff in front of sergey's face
like oh they're dead it's just like he's
so good at it either electric with the
long windy whatever he needs and also
his awareness too like the first game
like he was getting pestered with the
344 from Pon he was just like I know
this is the move you like to do in this
instance I'm going to challenge him
immediately this time with my magic P
it's just like you know like the quick
adjustments the quick call outs from
these players are so phenomenal high
level play
too I mean and that you could just tell
by watching him that's that's a kazuya
player that is not scared of risks right
but the funny thing is that he's a Kazu
player that's also not he didn't throw a
single hell sweep that game right pretty
much everything was just straight up is
making him whff punish making him make
poor decisions but he's also you know
cir is taking those risks right he's
trying to punish minus 14 with electrics
which you know it's not the easiest
thing to do you know what I mean it's
like just seeing things like that it's
like being just being you know
immediately aware to even like attempt
these punishes that's a kazuya player
and he's not someone that's scared of
doing it either which makes me as a
kazuya fan and a kazuya wnab be very
proud right and that's how you know the
difference between like Main and people
that just kind of mess around with him
you was right like sery the way he moves
like it's just did you guys see that
back one electric like he launched fakon
for doing back one that's literally only
my second time since the character has
come out that I've seen launch punish
anywhere and with the with the electric
of all things not a hop
kick to be able to hit the brakes from
your Crouch dash crou dash Wu Fame and
all that stuff and just be like I just
blocked the back one time till like
mhm I mean I that that's a Kaz that's a
kazuya main and Mishima mains you could
tell their their Mains when they have
the electrics like down four twos right
they don't need they don't need to to
always throw out the electrics and they
but when they need them it's like all
right yeah it's easy just just do an
electric whatever no big deal right the
Precision to be able to like stop on the
dime and be able to punish on
so good I'm so excited man so excited I
mean and that's one of those players too
that we know is great offline we've seen
him all offline but online too he is
still a beast man and you see the next
battle down there so someone the person
that did send uh Sergey two losers
actually was Na and N is another Mishima
player I believe you know we've seen him
for offline with kazuya but I believe he
is a Devil Jin main now so uh at least
that's what the smash bracket said right
there's a Cas sometimes smash brackets
they show off the characters and so I
saw Devil Jin so I'm not sure if he's
Still rocking the Devil Jin but na was
the one that sent sery to losers bracket
so uh pretty big match here coming up to
sapito no slouch himself sapito we did
mention earlier is a l link player from
Peru so very strong player himself uh
the link I think is the main but when he
brings out the L it also you know is
trouble and it's funny that Ling and Le
you know kind of that that that weird
connection right because we we do have
another person like that with the
Princess Link Trey you know we yeah
that's true we have a few of those but
it's very rare you know it's not a not a
combo that you see too often but when
you do see it it's like oh it's because
this guy's a tricky you know they they
like to they they like them they like
their stances they like their
evasiveness they like their cool stuff
you know the Kung Fu movie stuff too
like just matrixing on their stuff right
that's so cool it's so cool but man in
the land of mishas how do you compete
with these characters is what I'm going
that's what I'm most interested to see
think about sapito though that from what
I've seen him play he's not like you
know not this not disrespect to Trey but
tre's you know definitely more of a
tricky player right he's more like
willing to take take risks and you know
try to do setups whereas I've never felt
that way too hard about sapito you know
I've always felt that sapito he plays
the tricky characters but he plays them
more you know basic right more honest in
a sense but he but that doesn't
necessarily mean that like he's always
you know by the book right he takes
those risks but it's not as you know
know abundant as other other Ling or lay
players yeah I definitely know what you
mean but the Kaz okay love to see it
yeah I'm more excited for kazuya anyways
I didn't want devil J dude if you guys
remember Collision 2019 na the dragon
with the four down forward one fours
with a sidewall this
isul man that moment that was so sick
here we go though dragon's n showcase
God Nest is a down forward 14 Haven
almost right cuz you got the weird side
angles you know the the the the little
wall angles can help you out here I call
this stage the gy 124 Carnival man 124
playroom we're seeing the ha steps and
the animal transitions
already a super clean tech I love that
443 going to back turn and then duck in
case they try to Electric punish wow wow
wow
oh oh didn't get the jab unfortunate for
n there already used tail tail spin
yep the patience from both players man
the up up three usage from both the from
both Kazu players today has been
great play there getting him out of
safety there wasn't counter hit going
for the Mixie though and got it to
hit wow the snake fights were enough
great choice and you know that move the
second third fourth hit comes out so
fast that the armor is not going to be
able to slow it down they're going to
have to hold the whole string you got
hit by that first one you got to got to
get hit by all of them
mhm sapo definitely had the knowledge
there yeah that's going to be a close
set here sapo looking very strong I love
this the best ring with the snake stand
that is a new buff for lay in this
season where he got snake 41
transition and I really love yeah the
back turned down fours and like he's
he's playing this game where he's just
forcing n to come in where he's
uncomfortable I mean he's definitely
playing more aggressive too N I think is
trying to get those big whiffs and
trying to get some some sort of offense
going but his defense isn't there and
sapito's offense is nonstop I love the
way he uses just raw snake s dude that
is so sick gu the Parry after the time
tiger one plus two throw immediately
into play dead get out of trouble I
don't Scar the hell sweeps I'm the one
that
sweep I mean that was so clean sapito's
uh his uh offense man was just so on
point right those those Rave sweeps all
hit those mids all hit counter hit the
right strings mixed up the right timings
and that's lay in a nutshell right you
think that you think about Le you think
about all the stances but every every
stance has a mixup you know and that's
kind of what L is right he's a mix-up
heavy character but when his pressure
gets started like that and you want like
you're thinking like okay I just back up
let me get him the whiff and then I can
reset the entire situation sapito did
not allow that situation to happen once
he was like no you're in you I don't
care you don't have a chance to breathe
you're negative or plus there's no
neutral zero here I I really love the
way that he sets up his animal stances
of Raw After like you Tech roll after a
knockdown or something or a back turn
down four at tip range where it's not
going to trip and then he just starts
playing around that dance and he's just
like okay maybe I'll go to the next
dance maybe I'll go back to snake you
know and then it's like threatening with
tiger a little bit you know I love the
way that he's using the stances there
I've never seen a lay player be so
creative with like the stances in neutr
and he's gting so much mileage out of
the stance uh the snake stance 41 buff
yeah I mean you know right now watching
seito play it's like you know cuz I I
mean I know him more for his ling just
from the early Tekken s so you you know
lay wasn't always in Tech
not always in Tek s but watching this
it's like man this is a lay player for
real like so clean everything yeah
everything just feels like you know he
knew exactly the situations and he he
feels comfortable you know playing this
tricky character right lay is not
necessarily the easiest character to
pick up and learn but you can tell that
he's been playing lei for a while now
cuz he feels like you know a Master with
this character just like oh man this
Dojo is
sick we're getting the view from the
window keeping in from the window that
is sick is you think haachi broke that
wall himself like look it's a beautiful
night outside Kazumi breaks the wall
like look at this no was when they all
got jumped by the Jacks wasn't it round
what that wasn't taking five that was
like 20 years ago they couldn't afford
to fix it then come on come on
here he was dead for a minute that's
true I guess yeah you can't you can't
always ask dead people to to fix
things
just this one two hits with the razor
rush back away I love this like hit and
run
stop yeah n is trying to get his offense
going that's the reason why he chose a
small stage too yeah n just looks super
uncomfortable gets the counter it back
four nice combo there sets it up for Oki
toe kicks the way out
wow
wow The Stance just made it whip that
was amazing
gets the wall as well he's not going to
get the grounded hit for the scaling
unfortunate forito doesn't even matter
though 1 2 3 razor rush and then down
four tricky jerky man that was a scary
wall combo too but he's able to get it
na with a nice slow Parry going to get
the wall carry no mess up little sticky
on the dash yeah I mean that's a that's
a common mistake sometimes but nice
still gets the hell sweep wall
Splat gets scary here
too wo W the one one to snake this time
it was on block so n went for the out
sweep oh God that was terrifying woo the
check great check there by n great check
again the back two usage I love it yeah
na finally on the board I think the way
I think na finally decided that you know
what I can't be defensive anymore he's
got to check in certain instances and
Now seito setting up the panther stance
and got the
low oh down forward one two just got the
spike if he had done the other string it
would have been SP W standing two raw
dude he's definitely getting n to get
frustrated right now he was expecting
the back two forward they just threw out
the while sending to
Oh So Far Away easy pick up there from
na ne oh my God sidewall play though
sidewall play is ruing every problem oh
my God what's Theo always leaving
himself in stance after those funky
sidewall scenari is to capitalize on the
St Mi up after n gets
up
dang he's got the pressure here but
sapito fighting out wow with the wall
carry sidewalls don't affect me I got
the conversions man I'm a geometry
major got the launch going to carry to
the wall again
just just the last hit the whole thing
he wasn't expecting him to finish it na
in trouble this is trouble oh na is out
of the tournament to beat was that 6-0
in rounds 61 61 n got the one round in
that in that last game but unfortunately
man sapito the offense was just rolling
and you know he was able to get the
conversions when he needed to but ah man
it was just really clean yeah really
nice lay there like a lot of stuff was
so texbook and then like he just never
let himself be in a bad spot even though
he's just like sidewall coming into play
he's just always always made sure he
could like get himself safely into an
animal stand so that when n does wake up
he's forced to just guess 50/50s and he
took the right bets on those two and man
so well played by sepo there yeah you
know it really just felt like seedo had
no time to be on defense right it was
like cuz he kept pushing the offense so
much that when whenever n had any
opportunities to like get into offense
right really his offense was I need a
counter hit or I need a hell sweep right
like really was no in between there cuz
he could not get sapito to whip sapito
that was one thing he Speedo never
whiffed or got whiff punished really so
that was one big thing like outside of
that one random like Rave sweep that
ended up getting ducked other than that
like whip punishing was pretty minimal
there so you know that just means that
sepo was doing super strong here oh but
we can take a look here real quick at
the brackets this is what it's going to
look like this is top eight there we got
crew versus Abel Deo and sha versus Noel
in the winter side and loser side we got
LA maldita sery matzer sapito and
Jackson 5 man so big big top eight there
you know some of our favorite players
here cuz we you know we've been here in
uh the South America region I guess for
a while so I love these I love to see
some of these players play man I'm
excited I'm super excited man Abel right
there first match going up against crew
winner side I'm super all these matches
sound super sick man welcome back sergy
to the evil champ and Mal too that we
got to see in the the you know evil
competition as well great to see all
these great uh players staying
consistent still keeping up the grind
during the online region as well yeah
man I can't I can't wait for this top
eight man it's so exciting dude
because but we got some we got to to
show you guys some things real quick
here so just some things like these 10
10 o shirts I'm wearing this good ass
teken shirt the king shirt right now but
you guys can get your own very very own
King good ass teken shirt scan the QR
code on the screen right now or visit
10. merch these are limited times so
just make sure you know when you if you
guys really want these make sure to
order them like right now you know
because they're if you want them get
them now because they do go by fast and
uh this is a restocking of the king and
Marshall Law one and we also got the law
one in the yellow and black so if you
guys missed the first time around this
is this is the last time to try to get
it again who knows that they'll ever
come back after this but if you're a
martial law fan possibly a three Bar law
get them now 10- o./ merch and that's
not Laker gold rip uh you can all make
sure to follow follow us make sure to
follow the Dand dynamico team and the
Tekken team at borts on Twitter or on uh
YouTube as well as the Twitter account
Tekken Twitch account Tekken and
Facebook
Tekken oh man but the the next thing
though we're going to be doing after
this is our top eight but before we go
to that though we're going to go for a
quick break so don't go anywhere when we
come back top eight South America Tekken
online challenge 2021 will be continuing
so until then we'll see you guys soon
[Music]
can
all Bandit bearing 0 1
0 Bandit is down keep gun
range
enemy warships and Fighters
detecting missile confirmed
sunk arrived at
destination enemy reinforcements check
your rain
[Music]
arms
box
[Music]
to
my
n
hand
I've been waiting a long time for this
so this is what it's like to be a Super
Saiyan
[Music]
God
yo welcome back guys this is Tekken
online challenge 2021 you guys are
joining with me MK and my co-
commentator Rick yes sir man and you
guys saw the the quick trailers there
shout outs to Namco for showing us those
sick things you know we got Dragon Ball
and as well as Ace Combat man so you
know we obviously are here for some
tekking though and we are in our top
eight man South America top eight
qualifier this also let's let's not
forget powered by Astro the official mix
and headset of the Tekken online
challenge 2021 so make sure to be on the
lookout for some of those products out
there uh but man today our top eight we
got so many great players here and you
see the bracket here we got crew versus
Abel demro sha versus Noel La Malita
versus Sergey matzer and then sapito
versus Jackson 5 so a lot of Killers
here a lot of great match ups and a lot
of you know some some interesting
characters that we see especially on the
winter side you know not necessarily
characters that we see too much I would
say from the South America region but uh
it just also just because we don't see
them very often so characters in general
right like how often do you see a elizza
Eddie main along with the master Raven
main as the first matchup and Shia I'm
not too familiar with but Ricky was
telling me that Noel is actually a
steeve player so I'm really scouting
this match cuz you be I love me my back
ones and my down forward twos I the
everyone does except for everyone that
plays against Steve that that sucks
that's
right that's
right but yeah man I'm excited for these
top eights uh I I don't even know who to
say a favorite is right because
obviously I think for a lot of people
they recognize who Abel demro is right
he's the most uh traveled out of these
players right sponsored by Rock Dragon
the same team that sponsors players like
Chanel and ni so you know they they saw
something in him and you know obviously
with the characters that he plays Eliza
Eddie such a weird combo of characters
but I think it helps him because he can
almost switch up his Styles so
drastically for anybody it's a good
point yeah especially cuz like how often
do you see high level edes or eliz's
right and also Eddie kind of famous for
not really having the best type of siep
movement but because of that he utilizes
the back dash and the with punishment so
much more with Eddie you know back back
dash into it down for three plus for
such a big thing but we're not even
going to see that cuz the Eliza's coming
into play first going up against Cruz
Master Raven yeah I saw in the smash
bracket that Cruz uh early wins were
with Master Raven according to the
according to the bracket and you know me
I am like I'm a gain but I love Misa
Master Raven man I love her combos I
love her the way she plays I think she's
one of the most fun characters to
playing Tekken but also very difficult
right I don't I think it's hard to play
her in tournament so when you see actual
real master Raven just like a real
kazuya player right it's like you could
tell you could tell fight all right here
we go game number one though dishing
with the cor full one I love that move
for Raven and there's a lot of moves I
really like for master Raven as well I
think she kind of Falls in that same
same problem that like Fang has early on
where it's like too many good moves mhm
but it's like she has a lot of moves
that like they're good but they're all
kind of all sorts of tricky you know
right and finding the different reasons
and different purposes for it is going
to make a big difference but right there
magic 4 starting it off
for
aell immediately in the rear oh my God
instant air dive kicking that jab is
going to link off of that nice job Abel
paying close attention there ooh nice
punish too recognizing the second hit
yep's been kind of fishing with that a
lot dark wave one having many active
frames runs right into
it the extension after the back four the
squiggly leg oh the down jab and that is
one thing Abel's very good at just kind
of recognizing when the opponent wants
to attack but nice get a one plus two
now this time the fake out into the
low one two throw and it's good that's a
lot of damage yeah no throw break there
from a belu and the standing three
beautiful spacing got the back dash saw
the two two was whiffing and then CAU
the rear so it's not going to be a screw
so he kind of wasted the meter there
lucky break for crew plus frames after
the DI kick low per is the down jab can
he get to the wall here I don't think so
a little bit too far short just short
nice perfect punish you know that low is
minus 14 but Li is one of the few
characters in the game that does have a
14 frame launch yeah that does a lot
look at the
damage all right crew though got the
wall
positioning oh he tried to go for a one
throw it thing right down three from
Eliza and Akuma it's a special
cancelable low so a lot of times you
can't get a punish on it unless you low
Parry
it and more often than that you just
have to assume that it's safe right like
it's a regular like the first hit of a
of a string M especially El Lia cuz she
has her Fireball ex1 and the DI kicks
too the crew finding some hits here but
man aell so good with that magic
4 getting the extension with the what
meter trying to get the wall wowow
profile
profile I don't I don't even think what
hit was supposed to launch or anything
like that I think it's just crew I might
have thought that it was going to hit
right he saw that the whiff happened and
that's the one thing like two things
right there right low profile obviously
Eliza that move does you know reduce our
hurt box pretty low and master Raven's
rage Drive kind of has a high hit box so
it's like it's just a combination of two
great moves colliding and not not
reacting the way the master Raven player
wanted it to though yeah that's always
been a very popular thing with uh old
school Ravens for 4 3 right it never had
the best hit boox and uh it kind of
carried over to the race drive too so
seeing that happen there was a a pretty
common sight I think for I don't know if
theel did that like super big brain with
the down for on purpose get the rage
drive out of the way cuz that sounds
crazy to me but then the way that it
worked out it just
it I mean does seem pretty comfortable
in the match up though he seems to know
the punishes right he seems to know okay
you know after certain string should
stay blocking because I know that this
is a launcher counter at launcher if I
do anything crazy right so I think he
really it seems like he's definitely
comfortable with the match same thing
with crew Honestly though I think Cruz
you know he feels comfortable with the
match too but he just hasn't been able
to get these big hits especially with
the master of Raven too with wall stages
you get one hit and carry to the wall
that's a lot of damage that other
characters can't really achieve like her
so yeah that's the most fun part but man
we're going into the infinite stage so
you know uh Master Raven actually
infinite stage damage too she does great
and she she doesn't have to actually
readjust her combos or freestyle it a
bit to adjust for the walls sping now
she could just go for full combo and
then she has the unscaled grounded it at
the end too man that is beautiful that
is my background whenever we commented
icfc I love those blue and purples man
round but you see here crew I think's
taking it to the stage try to outplay
Abel but also you know probably
utilizing the fact that Abel can't have
these walls now to put the pressure on
so if is going to win this he's going to
have to win this straight off of you
know hard Tekken infinite real Tekken y
wow and that's a generic throw going to
get some meter off that as well I SAR
her her regular throw is the only throw
I've seen hit the most right yeah no
other characters strange right I don't
know what it is it's that one throw that
I've seen the most of out of any other
throw round two yeah that's the only one
for Eliza that builds meter for her too
so dang the down for three
[Music]
antire down for three such a good move
at the start nice blocks W any one going
to get the launch y the whole thing all
right goes for the
staple oh these standing for fours from
Abel have all been hitting though
luckily that was a counter hit but dude
they it seems like a normal hit launcher
the way of Bell's using it my goodness
back one two just threading the needle
mhm saw the little back dash saw crew
whiffing and immediately just went for
the counter hit there got the launch AB
Bel now working so good that should be
that there just kind of trying to press
the offense there just trying to force
it aell had it scouted with the jump
back the exi kick and that's the best
part about Eliza right that makes her
jump extra scary is that other than like
Akuma and GE her jump back she can still
come in with the ex yeah I mean that's
the one thing you always got to you got
to treat it like a back dash it's like
all right she jumped back you got to
kind of you know be patient because you
know that dive can come at any time but
nice crew trying to get this round here
just a little bit out oh dive kick three
counter kick in the I know right three
more dive kicks afterwards oh just
missed time just missed time I think he
did a little too early on that one yeah
the tech ended up just being like Oh
Perfect I the tech trap ended up
trapping yourself
right dark here just trying to keep him
out then you see the dark wave ones com
into
play oh the counter
hit2 and burns the meter for the extra
damage look at the damage them out with
the Fireballs now just fortive I think I
think he was setting a best he's just
like trying to punish me with knee try
to punish me with knee but then the the
dark wave one is just this forth field
it's like a sonic boom it's a Aus
reflector yeah yeah so good man I mean
that was so smart from from a Bel to
right recognizing that he had the lead
and obviously you know one thing about
one thing about Eliza is that her
Fireball game's not the best right
because it doesn't reach full screen but
it does a lot of damage it's fast and
it's annoying right it's still a
fireball you got to remember that so you
know to fight around it can be pretty
pretty hard and pretty annoying
especially when you can't really like
deal with the one that was stays right
in front of her because you're thinking
like oh she's going to throw the one
that's far I got to run in and then he
throws the wall then you can't run in
you get hit so mhm yeah perfect job myel
I love that you brought up that her
Fireball does a lot of damage and I and
I felt that because I'm like damn he's
he's saying that from an Akuma player
perspective he's like her Fireball does
the most damage out of all the Fireballs
that is true because you because as a
Akuma player when you trade it with it
you're like that's not a good trade I'm
losing every time every time we trade
Fireballs I'm losing oh my God the life
deficit thing came over to Tekken in
that way but yeah as you can see here
Rock dragons of bell moving into the
Winner's final spot sitting nice and
pretty waiting on the winner of sha
versus no coming up next and crew going
to be moving into the loser side uh
waiting on the winner of llad versus
sery Master yeah and also sepo and
Jackson 5 to round out the losers
bracket at the end there uh this top
eight is going to be pretty crazy but
Bell obviously in the top three already
not necessarily a big surprise right I
think the majority of people will
recognize do recognize AEL as one of the
strongest not the strongest player out
of South America but you know obviously
he's he's strong for a reason right and
he's strong because the people that he
plays against are also very strong so
you know this the rest of this
tournament is going to be definitely
hard for him to uh to try to take it
can't wait I can't wait to see this next
one we got a Steve Fox in top eight with
Noel and I I'm curious to see who sha
plays and why is there a question mark
sh it's not UNS sure sometime sometimes
you're unsure you just like like what do
you want to sign up as I don't know sh
question Mar okay yeah that's your
name I love it I love it then after that
we're going to have llama ladta versus
sergy
Master almost we got it man I'm excited
though man just because I want to see
some of these especially for you know
some of the characters that or the
players that we haven't seen like
obviously Noel and sha are two players
that I'm not necessarily too familiar
with so I'm excited to see what what
kind of Tekken these two players can
bring we're going right into it here we
go what's the character selection for
Shell I'm
curious and it's Fang let's go Tekken
five
boys Steve versus
Fang this is a classic this is what I
started man when these characters were
around like
this I mean Fang you know obviously got
a ton of Buffs here in this uh in this
stage of uh Tekken right the with the
newest patch Steve always has been super
strong always been super
annoying fight they need to make them
more
annoy yeah they didn't make him no more
annoying they called him fak
BR he does have some
Ste oh guess the down back three counter
hit these are the Buffs we're talking
about right oh it's only 12 oh but it
gets to peekabo to as the homing attack
works out gets the wall too
that saves the wall break the M does
more damage
anyways oh was in range yeah that's what
I was shocked about oh keep the
plus wow the down back one catches Noel
out there sha taking that first round
the spear Al
luo oh that is 14 decides not to punch
it I stuck whoa I love the usage of that
yeah really utilizing these big power
moves from Fang oh back one though
that's all he
gets falls up on the guaranteed hit with
the stomp ton of
damage playing this keep out game with
the Ford four and the four four
followups Noel didn't fight yeah Noel
basically turning Steve into just a
straight whiff punishing character right
now and it's doing work right
now and that's kind of the part with
Steve right like Sonic Fang is fantastic
for the range and the speed but the
damage is not that scary so he's Shia is
kind of like willing to whisk it there
but Noel staying solid getting as many
Sonic Fang whip punches as you can get
the damage where you can fuzzing for the
low Perry on the 10 hit just in case
guess what there wow out of nowhere yeah
from downtown too woo back handle was
good punch Perry set up no go get side
stepped yeah Noel's making sha whiff a
lot nice block too sh he's doing a lot
of dances a lot of forward four a lot of
back Temple but now he's not getting
anything
started yeah it felt like like it feels
like he's still playing the same game
but now Noel's just like all right I'll
just block it and wh punish yeah Noel
has adjusted for sure okay we got the
guard break course for to the hit
grounded oh the fish hook don't go
nowhere there's the back one free
shoulder oh wasn't quite there not quite
enough with the one two had a good time
yeah sh he's willing to throw out that
kle step even from real
close this is so scary you know oh my
God
trickery he's doing the fox step back
swing blow on his life and he got the
blue for blue oh my
God
what oh my God that was so ballsy from
Shia but he brought it back it's like
one of those things it's like man you
shouldn't be that confident to do the
between the legs you know slam dunk
while you're down 10 but it's like like
no no I'm doing 3602 don't worry about
it no scope yeah trust me I got I got
all the strats oh see that's that's what
he's playing around with and got the
lead now sha finally in the lead in this
set yeah you tell that's kind of the way
sha likes to play right he likes to
whiff but try to catch Noel running in
and it helped out the first couple
rounds but right now it's real real real
close a lot of this trickery y coming
out of sh I love it the forward for back
turn manual back turn just making this
really hard for Noel to get in and the
back temples every once in a while too
mixed in look at that gets him to burn
the rage Drive rocket launcher finds
the fo
stop yeah he had to go and he went for
the mid mid Noel didn't bite he was like
there's no mix it's a mid High mix
there's no mix if I just Dam block it I
would I would have
ducked I would have ducked and lost sick
that was so good that was that that
honestly that that last situation at the
end there was pretty scary for both
players honestly but you know Noel
clutching it out being able to take the
take the win after getting pressured
like that so much right in that last
round too it felt like he was going to
lose because it just felt like
everything that Shia was doing was was
hitting right every whiff was a up into
something else but you know Noel just
played it cool played it slow and then
got the one pickup and that's all that
mattered so good first game I really
love that mid-range game that Shia's
playing it's very classic thing yeah
yeah very classic with forward fors get
you to come in or if the forward Four
Tags you as you come in it's a launcher
it's really hard to punish cuz that back
turn keeps himself safer and he can turn
around by down all kinds of tricking it
and sometimes he does the manual one
sometimes he does back kampo and it just
makes it really hard to like know how to
approach Fang as a character it's like
if I overextend back kampo into hot kick
is a real threat back cample to into
shoulder hurts you know all that stuff
hurts you you see them back turn they're
like okay maybe I should extend here but
that's when you get hit by the sweep or
the back turn punches or something so
you know Fang Fang's one of those
characters where even though he whiffs
it doesn't feel safe you know it's just
like you feel like you still have to
wait it out a little bit but oh oh look
at theit for the island and we got the
day and night evening transitions let's
go all right into game number two sh up
one game bringing it all the way back
with the Fang I mean yeah Noel brought
my
B let's see if sh can make this come
back here oh the jab doesn't get the
convert though scking with the Fang oh
my what he the wow he's not scared to
throw out that cample step whether he's
whether he's in range seven or range one
dude he did wow he did Back kle to
forward kle in his face I love
this going to hide there get the side
step four though yeah willing to take
that risk there the side steps so good
right just in order just to create
create whiffs but then to to be able to
S up four hit a loow that can launch
from close range is so so nice you have
to be really wary about it but if it
hits man you get you get that's what
we're talking about oh oh but gets the
counter hit flicker too this is going to
be
big wall break too let's see option here
goes for the Sonic Fang running oie
makes Fang eat the
sand professional dirt uh sand taster
that's the worst dude you ever sand in
your mouth is the like one of the worst
feelings in the entire world sand it's
co it gets everywhere I
hate round all right tied up here Noel
get in that first round in the second
game
here oh nice mini on it caught him
stepping or hitting a button there back
one to he's so plus that you can't do
anything pick it up oh another flicker
to counter launcher everything felt like
a drop there but it dropped into a
counter hit launcher every
time nice block on the people down
too wow what a challenge with that back
sping blow have to running two oh good
block though and that's the thing in
this matchup right it's just like uh
yeah Steve can't launch down back three
but the W setting one two hurts man just
eating like two of those is almost like
a launch
anyways oh get him with the frame trap
he down one into the 10 count yep down
back 3-2 to close it out there Noel
taking it two Z over sha what to say
convincingly because it was pretty
scrambly it was pretty heavy but I mean
at the end there Noel definitely
clutched it out right just played Super
solid played very very safe and Compact
and Clos it out so nice job that's not
going to be it for sha either he's going
to have one more shot at it in the loser
side but yeah I like a lot of his stuff
uh seeing from uh seeing his fang like
the the the old school Fang flavor you
know just seeing just seeing some of the
the the characters that have been in
Tekken for a while and this uh seeing
these players bring out the old school
style where it's just like a lot of the
forward four and new Neal and then the
back sway and all that stuff it's just
like yes yes I love to see it love to
see yeah but it's and it's not even just
an old school style Fang too he's still
bringing the new school one where a lot
of kampo steps a lot of these you know
Tekken seven strats so he doesn't really
play one way but he he he he melds both
play Styles so well love it love it but
as you guys can see there Winner's final
is going to be against Rock dragons AB
Bel day marro versus BTM Noel excited to
see that yeah but the loses bracket's
going to be beginning soon and we got
some killers there too as well uh man
it's going to be kind of scary though
man it's going to be a little scary
there for for every everybody but the
winner side's looking clean the loser
side's looking dirty that's how it is in
tournaments right yeah yeah man it's
it's a blood bath and losers B
absolutely and we're going to get laita
going up against sery coming up next and
I think that's going to be a
Maru right I think it's a Marduk versus
kazuya maybe Miguel cuz he also does run
a every now and then but M seems to be
the baby the the main tournament
character so I mean and let's be honest
M's buff yeah I mean maro's kind of been
the Hot Topic ever since uh his release
and even more so now with a lot of
players like really bringing out the
Tekken 7 Marta Claver and uh he's just a
monster man his Okami is crazy The
Tackle is as strong as ever and uh yeah
his low game is pretty terrifying too
like his low game is Just like they're
all not very traditional lows but
they're all very good lows in its own
right like and also that down for w buff
but man let's take another look here we
are doing the South America online
Masters event here today and that and if
you guys can see on the on the calendar
here coming up tomorrow is going to be
the EU region and then continuing to the
week after that and then we got Africa
covering up Asia write these dates down
and then we have the Regionals finals
coming up in later on in the year in
November going all the way to January as
you guys can see there definitely write
those down oh but we see here on
Twilight conflict too we got sery versus
laita we got Marduk versus kazuya and I
mean I think sergey's definitely been
making a fan of out of a lot of people
recently with his online
play his kazuya has been looking so sick
and he's doing it in front of two kazuya
stands TI even noticed that eagle in the
middle of the stage right there before
what that just blew my mind Hey these
firefighters are watching a fight rather
than taking out a fire they're too how
do you like this stage really just makes
you realize how incompetent the tech
like world is
fight that is so
funny wow what a low
Parry get the wall just short canel it
nice yeah oh didn't work out very
interesting guess a low Parry again yeah
good low Parry o triy to get a tech trap
maybe but nice pressure explosion finds
a down for one immediately after that
the pressure doesn't
stop oh
no legs little boy legs gets the rage
Drive activates the devil form what we
going to see hell become mid here oh
running three oh down back two get off
of it oh
favor 51 pixel yeah barely harat's
Healthcare save him and wall carry oh
and we're going for the ground throw mix
that's a 50/50 oh wall bounce that was
so sick side step two goes into VTS to
evade the electric so
smart oh nice gets the big boy wall
combo man but every time dude Seri
gotone low Parry three times in two
rounds so
far that's big right he's making those
reads on those hell sweeps and oh my go
oh my God no when is it going to stop
man he's still partying takes the
guaranteed flip over doubles up on the
low takes the frames yeah Seri just
seems to be having a little trouble
trying to get any offense started here
it's
crazy wow beautiful back Cash electric
with punish got the wall break he's
going to break it yep carry to the other
wall no goes for
charge I love
it has the lead he could have tried to
punish
interrupts oh good
block Mala playing very patient but he
does have blue Drive expended didn't get
the steel penal doesn't matter gets the
whip punch on the down forward one Seri
is still staying
solid
fight wow loosening up wa I saw a
glimpse of that in the last I love it
wow the combo spacing Awareness on that
down forward one double yeah you know
how I used I I like to say like how how
certain characters have easy combo
routes to change it up like kazuya
doesn't have a combo route it's
constantly
evolving that was so sick oh nice W car
and that's the throw Mixie and he gets
the grounded
unskill Marduk is a
monster I mean yeah when you make those
right reads too but now but it's just
not even that though right you got to
give it up for lal's his defense right
those first two rounds he won straight
up off of those low pares right he and
those were low pares on Hell sweeps too
so it wasn't necess like oh he saw the
hell sweep and he was low par no he's
just low paring at the right time
because he knows like I need the low
Perry something and I have a feeling Ser
is going to go for a low here and every
time he's got a low Perry he's
capitalized on it you know so big big
win there you know we do know I do know
Sergey has other characters I don't
think he'll go to them but you know
there was a zafina pick for that I know
that he's he's known for so I don't see
it happening though but his K looks so
nice right now it's just one of those
things where uh L mod is just playing so
well right now you know actually now
that I recall I think when they played
at I think they played at evil and he
used a Fina on to beat him so that could
actually come into play here yeah you're
right I mean he does play zapen too
really strong z a secondary but
everybody loves the kazuya man how can
you not it's the the sexy wo the
electrics the how can you not love that
it's hard it's hard to not like kazuya
he's too sick yeah also too like since
ladito was getting so many of the low
pares on point uh Seri went for the 443
and the one time that he got it
unfortunately up Whi yeah he had two
combos that seemed like they both could
have hit and they both just whiffed and
it could just be because Muk is one of
those characters where he's big but he's
also small for some
reason return Mar old hert box just
saying Violet systems God I love it my
favorite OST and Tekken 7 let's
go I bet you during the during this off
time you see all those monitors on the
side I bet you they show twitch
streams
yeah creating combat
4.0 while watching twitch
streams wow called them out on that too
lad thre that out from downtown and look
at the combo damage there Sergey he got
warmed up from the big boy combos though
with the F ROM earlier yeah the way that
he wasn't Tech rolling there Ser had it
scouted he's like oh this guy wants to
go for the low he wants to go for the
low for the tackle pressure afterward
yep o that down bag too doing so much
work gets the guaranteed doesn't want to
carry wants to D oh he
tried not the punish he he wanted though
but that was very interesting the W
standing one is cancel pressure doesn't
matter gets the race dve devil form
activated are we going to see the mid
electric I mean sery loves this devil
form but man devil form always to each
just seems like a it never works out I
know I know I want to see it work
out all right two two point oh into the
443 getting
duck oh wa see I'm telling you man these
Kaz combos are just all
freestyles nothing nothing is like a set
combo right nice zy bringing it all the
way back look at that
fight up the electrics Too Close round
gets the high
crush a lot more 443 now a lot more 443
lot of detail challenging with the down
back
twos
oo to do not scared to throw out that
wall signing one he loves that move such
a great check Mar fastest wall siging
attack
andt it's not even going to
matter three rounds Seri take it over
Lalita to tie it up one1 man it looked
good too man that was very very clean
just solid kazuya play right getting the
mixups in getting the launchers in and
even you know Lal deta he did get that
one round a lot of counter hits but I
mean that's M too right M has that
ability so it's a close ass set it is
very very close and then that set too it
was just like he remembered from the
data from the first game he's like
you're low pairing everything I'm going
to forward 43 everything then like deal
with that a lot more forward 43s a lot
more mids but then that's what opens up
the hell sweeps again right so that's
why you know you might see a hell sweep
now and then because like you know now
you're worried about the 443 so if I'm
I'm the tournament player here in this
scenario I'm scared you know the first
round he had the low defense second
round the mid defense wasn't there and
now for me the data is reset it's just
like what do I do now go back to the
lows go back to the mids hard you know
hard to call out you throw them no wait
that doesn't work either cuz if they
start blocking low you get launched uh
you don't do anything you block that's
also good we're we're scared out here
mhm that throws a huge wrench in the
gear right
there oh man but yeah good adjustment by
sergy there in game number two I mean
Lama did get that one round but for the
most part it seemed very controlled Sur
there and we got the character switch
Yeah and honestly I was not anticipating
that I was like I'm fairly confident
he's gonna stick with with Marduk but
the Miguel does come out right and the
Marduk was doing so well very
interesting
choice obstacle to Miguel Duo d
cidio as ever like I never get to see
that high up in
yeah I never like I was looking just at
that one little like Star like statue
thing in the back I was like that is
really crazy that you can't ever see it
yeah you'll never see it well you only
notice it during during rars and stuff
when someone gets thr in the high in the
air
Co yeah so clean sery you Ser is just
like it's
it's second second hand second nature
right just like back dash immediately
does wave Dash yep wow the funky never
and the hell sweeps are out the play
side wall turns into a forward wall why
not hell sweeps are back baby yeah man
this is not looking good for Malita here
oh triy to whiff punish or block punish
with lost 912 don't know if that's
punishable only 11 actually really for
for looking generic low usually those
are the ones that are like minus 20
[Music]
mhm
W dude Ser is speeding going faster now
he's teing it up that was sick he's
turning it up now short unblockable
car yo St C too dude he's
loose yes Lal going to need to do
something big here unfortunately he
doesn't have tackle so he's got to do it
all with
Miguel oh Miguel's got short baby arms I
know the one two didn't even reach the
wall standing
2 oh get that power Crush out of here
here he said yeah he's like
yeah this getting crazy getting
crazy yeah every time Miguel says yeah
he get
launched yeah Get Ready To Fly that's
me but good stuff to sery there lad the
Miguel didn't end up working out but
great try man great run once again yeah
I mean I think maybe he just felt like I
don't know if I can do it with M Maro
right now maybe maybe he just had to be
like I got to close this out with Miguel
you know but unfortunately it wasn't it
I mean obviously right you you're going
up against the champion the evil
champion sergy who does advance now will
end up facing crew in the losers
quarterfinal uh close match but you know
unfortunately lad finishes in seventh
place but nice showing our next match in
the losers bracket is going to be sapito
versus Jackson 5 as well and man this is
crazy top eight man I mean you know
Sergey didn't look like the you know the
first game in that last set looked kind
of shaky right but definitely just he he
shook off the kazuya wave Dash cobwebs
or whatever and just started going ham
like look I just I don't understand how
he just revs up his kazuya like that
right first game was just trying to
figure it out like how the opponent's
defending how they're reacting oh you're
low playing everything next game the
mids come out and then game three did
you guys see his move he's just like
he's just like deal with it what are you
going to do what are you going to do now
I'm flexing on you now it's always one
of those things too it's like Kaz so I
do know that like some kazuya players
Kaz players but mhima players like they
want to you know warm up they want to
feel comfortable with their characters
in tournament and sometimes they just
don't feel that way about the character
in tournament right they might not have
the execution that day right so I don't
know some chars like kazuya Mains though
for me like the ones that only play
kazuya they never feel like they have
their
uh inputs compromised at any point you
know they always feel like they have
their they have their wave dashes they
have their execution ready it's just
whether or not they can just you know
perform in the clutch right but they
always seem to just like I can always do
an electric it's just whether or not I
can do it in the clutch you know or I
can do it a hell sweep or any of these
you know these key kazuya components but
for for Sergey it just feels all second
nature it's like all right everything is
so easy I know how to do all of this
I've been doing this since Tekken Tag
one it's no problems and then the way he
just dude like the speed control too
like slow fast slow fast like like
whenever he needs it he could just flip
the switch whenever he needs it and
that's so good for setting the pace and
like making it awkward for your
opponents like thinking like oh it's h
sweep oh no he just did an extra three
more wavel in my face and now I don't
know how to block you know but here we
go and then you think like oh it's not
now it's my turn to attack you as soon
as you swing that's when he back dashes
electric you know so yeah yeah we saw
that many times too yeah Jackson Five
though going back to the namesake of the
jackm oo look at this dude we're basic
we're we're and this is basically
infinite Azure just where we found the
wall
I love this stage it's like my favorite
one of my favorite wall stages in this
game all right jack a five with the Jack
like you said sapo with the Lei I think
sapito is pretty much only Lei as it
says in his online name sapito Lei yeah
his L looks good man really good
[Music]
yeah wow oh wow red the throw attempt
there got the launch too big boy
combo doesn't get the defense on the
second low that that that string has no
mix yeah that string has no mix if that
happens takes the plus spr doubles up
double patty cake
slam oh my God now Jackson Five with the
huge lead just the pokes coming out
heavy oh immediately into the one 5050
time
wow wall not there oh I can't believe
you
immediately challenge immediately
challenge with the ball standing for
nice job there from Jackson 5 ooh down
for two gets blocked but no punish from
sapito wow that's the second hit rock
saved himself from getting launched
string just finishes it out love the the
mid-range tools that both these guys are
using right now that's down forward four
at the perfect spacing 50/50 again P to
the safe mid caught the back got the
back got turn around
deep wh punches looking for the last
High just in case oh dear Lord oh dear
Lord
oh oh nice Jackson Five with the down
forward one perfect perfect place to put
that there too Jackson Five is so good
at finding these forward two side step
twos right now and even the
debugger challenges imediately after the
mid nice side St that was wh punish he
stepped into the wall standing 4 too
like the same kind of direction oh the 4
four caught him trying to step no the
way that he bounced off from the wall
for one hit before double P kick slam o
should be
it I like the layers I like the layers
yeah Lost Jack Jack right there with the
full couch down forward two he could do
mid after the second hit or high or low
so he decided to go for the mid into low
and then the double layers is if they
stay grounded the low would still hit
grounded there and if they got out to
defend they have to guess that it's
going to be mid low version so good
choice there good choice to Jackson Five
yeah I mean Jackson Five also you know
he did see he did see some some little
uh weaknesses there right the throw
breaking game wasn't the best from
sapito so you know I think he's he's
that's the reason why he's been throwing
out those throws you know even though
they did get launched that first round
he doesn't care because he needs you
know I think as a jack player you need
to throw you know you need to know how
to throw and Jack does have a real throw
game so yeah uh and you know Jack 5 long
long time Jack player so he knows
exactly how to play the character very
well uh and I mean he just looks so good
too sapito you know he just had the he
had some mixups you know some
opportunities but at the end there just
just got beat I think uh the last match
we saw of sapito he was utilizing the
snake stance a lot and that's something
that he's not going to be able to use as
freely against Jack especially these big
body characters where their arms are
more forward and their legs are farther
back because snake 41 in that sense uh
even if the four could hit the four is
really hard to hit because their legs
are further retracted and also if the
four does hit a lot of times the one
could whip even if the four hit because
that would that make it like punishable
I believe so yeah I believe
so could be
nasty all right here we go though going
into last day on Earth again I don't
know where these zombies are coming from
but they
here round
one
fight was the counter hit oh got counter
that one was a counter just threatening
with the stances I love it oh that was
the counter he had it he had it doesn't
matter got the Razor Rush mid Zito first
round it feels like when Zito gets his
offense going he does a really really
good job but Jackson 5 is also someone
that challenges a lot he will Challenge
on your offense so I like both these
players uh challenges a lot like Jackson
5 in the neutral a lot of forward two a
lot of size two really working out for
him soito too sometimes when he's
getting pressured the one one has been
up and out a lot 443 gets wh punish
there oh he's also been getting a lot of
s fours as well too so he's definitely
has his movement into launchers
available but
woo so scary play so
patience oh my
gosh a tricky one nice going under the
two jab with the high Crush well played
by sepo great choice yeah very
good oh got him with the mix straight up
walk up ball standing one he made him
think about it with just that one low
beforehand oh I love the way he's
stepping with him Jackson 5 keeping his
back against the wall but aedo gets the
play dead launcher yeah that play dead
such a good move to to make people
whiff it's kind of like a aop of his own
right Jackhammer whip going back in with
the razor Rush keeping up the
pressure but Jackson Fire not afraid to
start swinging back I love the
challenges with the down back one from a
lot of these animal transitions it's
really forcing uh sedo to like throw
away his animal stance offense to go for
the low Parry or the low Bloss yeah very
very good and also thing I'm likeing
about Jackson 5 right now is that he is
throwing these strings out but Speedo
catch him with 443 going to get it to
the other wall just yes sure and the
angle rman is good not going to get the
grounded him to set up the Oki properly
uh-oh dude get the
one that was counter hit too that was
dude his fingernails oh my God Jackson
Five Jesus what a come back oh nice
punish but the up for three big counter
huge opportunity I I think you might be
right yeah I think it might have been
could the throw cost him that time oh
the back turn set that's a new thing in
Tekken 7 throws are counter hitable now
oh timing call out and Jackson 5 had the
right move choice but not the right
timing sedo answers back yeah I mean
that's one thing too right we said that
the Jackson 5 he was getting getting a
lot of mileage off these throws with
that throw cost in that last round there
because of that counter hit State
unfortunate but that's how it goes
sometimes looking real good now that I
think about tkken s's throw syst still
I'm like this you can counter it throws
they should hella make them just normal
pranks man that hurt so much so that's a
great answer from seedo there like he he
saw that you know that's a very common
thing that Jack do does right uh instead
of going for the two un punish even
though something might be too
unpunishable it does more damage but
just doing the single two jab gives Jack
more frame Advantage so a lot of times
you'll see Jack players opt to go for
just a single two jab a lot of times the
single two into Jackhammer for a big mid
or the throw game starts opening up
after the single two jab but zpo had it
scouted with that up four three yeah and
that was a clean up 4 three too got the
counter hit got the launch got
everything else sapito making that
comeback there so it was close set here
between Jackson Five and seito
uh I I I guess we'll probably still see
the same characters I've been wrong
before I've been wrong pretty much all
the time so we'll see how his Negan
sticks I'm already like you're you're
already calling it out there it's going
to be
honestly is doing good I really like the
checks he does like during the animal
stances but who knows yeah yeah the down
back ones and the downforward ones
whenever leay goes into an animal stance
and wants to transition to a second one
those are great checks there by Jackson
5 yeah Jackson 5 man he's been playing
so well here but seito you know making
these
comebacks yeah really enjoying seeing
his legay hey this this place is still
on fire where are the
fire fire B they're enjoying the
imaginary
fight
fight wh I know was sitting down there
with his with his head poed up like are
you done yet I'm going launch you he
find every single one man oh back R
catch wow extended it and that cost him
there too nice launch there seito going
to get the lead look at the damage oh
nice punish wow 4
for2 didn't have the wall oh my God he
he had the one one or the one two that
was
counter man a lot of lot
of that's happening crazy I don't yeah I
don't want to call them mistakes cuz I
don't think any of those were mistakes
those are just odd situations
mhm oh going for the low Crush but is a
slower move leads him back to
Jin oh setting up the animal dances here
we go no it's not that bad psych nice
good step yeah soo's real good at
stepping in that direction getting that
launch too now look at this two rounds
up on Jackson 5 about to eliminate
Jackson 5 from the tournament yeah using
that down forward two into snake stce
transition got the grounded it this time
so it worked
out wow oh the counter that's not good
that's a lot of damage that's a lot of
damage oh good for the big boy comble
too all the hits of the razor Rush look
at his
life never does
[Music]
that oh just out of R but not punished
oh my God Jackson 5 is throwing out some
heavy moves and the throw gets ducked
once again that's the thing man if you
rely on the throws too much because you
think it's like a a weakness that you
can exploit against an opponent and then
they have the read on the throw and then
they duck it that's the that's the
Tekken mini game around throws right
there yeah throws are only punishable if
they duck and punish you other than that
if they break a th it's not really a
punish it's a
block as you can see here though this is
the top six now that we see uh Abel Deo
versus Noel will be our Winner's final
in the losers quarters though we got
crew versus Sergey matzer and then sha
versus sapito so a lot of great matches
coming up here uh a lot of great
characters but man this is a close close
top eight here has been great so far
this has been great so far but once
again let's give a shout out to some of
these great ass shirts and you guys can
snag a couple of these yourself the good
ass Tekken shirt featuring King back in
stock now in the black and blue uh you
know these were some of the first
edition shirts that they had over at 100
you guys can check them out at 10- o./
merch we also have the law one that
makes a return in the black and the
yellow if you guys want to check them
out make sure to check them out here 10.
gmer merch and then make sure to follow
all the socials here you can follow
Bandai Namco Esports atbn Esports on
both Twitter and YouTube as well as the
Tekken Community you can follow them on
Tekken all on either Twitter Facebook or
twitch yeah it's been a great top eight
so far I am super excited to see more of
these matches oh man so good we got we
got the evil we got like the evil Champs
like kind of still alive right but we
also got a B Dem Maestro Still rocking
around so a lot of cool lot of
interesting match ups here we I mean we
got character specialist like Master
Raven and lei here so lot of cool top
eight turn
match ups coming up here yeah I've been
really enjoying sapito's Lei man just
like the I it's just so interesting to
see because it's just like I'm so used
to fighting and seeing Suk and leay
right because I've been fighting his lay
for like 10 years plus right and then
just seeing a different slight take on
the same character how he uses the
animal stances how he uses the back turn
to create space it's so much fun to
watch right after yeah but before we
continue on for this top eight we're
going to take a quick break so don't go
anywhere we'll be right back for more
top eight from the Tekken online
challenge South America
2021 play as Goku and experience the
story of Dragon Ball Z in the action RPG
Dragon Ball Z kakarat plus a new power
awaken set for Nintendo
switch
in this game The Magnificent original
story you will play will include the
most famous scenes and even completely
new ones never before seen in previous
games this is the real Goku experience
from spectacular battles free flop and
sharing meals with many dishes to
developing relationships with many many
characters in addition exclusive
Nintendo switch features add Much More
To Your Dragon Ball Adventure
[Music]
let's explore Dragon Ball Z in all its
Glory with its numerous features and
gorgeous
Graphics in the power level system every
action you take with Goku leads to his
growth increases power level through all
actions including fighting meeting
people and
eating
level up by defeating enemies and
gaining
experience the more powerful enemies you
defeat the more experience you will gain
growing even stronger with every
battle you can also gain experience by
fishing hunting animals and fighting
dinosaurs after cook up and eat all the
ingredients you gather from around the
Dragon Ball world with every meal your
strength and power will increase and you
can even get temporary buff
effects the more you eat the stronger
you become so don't forget about
cooking in particular the courses
prepared by Goku's wife Chi-Chi are
excellent and will have an even better
effect in training grounds you will grow
Goku's power by fighting against Z
Warriors powerful enemies from the past
and even
yourself after defeating each opponent
you will unlock a new special
[Music]
attack Z orbs are essential items that
can be collected on the field or
obtained by defeating enemies by using
these Z orbs in your super attack skill
tree you can enhance the special attack
you have learned through training or
learn KN how passive skill skills that
will always remain
[Music]
effective in order to advance your
adventure connection with your friends
is
essential by completing the main story
and sub stories you can earn Soul
emblems which deliver a variety of
Effects by placing them on the community
[Music]
board certain combinations of characters
can result in a bonus so it is important
to consider character compatibility and
place them appropriately stronger than
Dad in the future I I don't know about
that where's your Sayan Pride go on say
you're going to surpass
me like you just accept him saying that
only on Nintendo switch bonus content is
included from a new power awakens Parts
one and two where you can earn a brand
new power through training and also
fight beerus and golden
Frieza
Additionally the option to select the
difficulty level of the game from Easy
normal or hard is also
included there are even subquests where
characters will become
[Music]
playable a story for all Dragon Ball
fans the real Goku experience with
incredible depth and beautiful Graphics
pre-order today to secure even more
bonus content only available when you
pre-order and only at participating
[Music]
retailers
players
win I don't know what to be excited
about here I know you're excited about
Steve Fox you're always excited excited
about Noel Steve Abel I just always I
love watching his Liza and Eddie as well
and also sapito has been really fun to
watch for me I I mentioned that right
before we went on break but man his lay
is uh really something else really clean
too so it's been really fun to watch
yeah man I can't wait to see it
obviously these guys are playing for you
know just just ranking points and all
that stuff but a lot of Pride here too
right you know there's a lot of lot of
great Tekken players here you can see
the bracket right here we got Abel Deo
Noel in the winners finals losers
quarters we got crew sergy Mater as well
as Shia and sapito uh and these guys are
playing you know obviously I'm sure
these guys have played each other a ton
right but at a certain point you know
when you get to these tournaments right
where you know it's like all right I'm
I'm one of six remaining and I know the
other five players are great players so
it's like that's when you start to feel
a little bit more like all I got
something to prove here you know like I
I want to see if I can hang I want to
see if I can hang with these guys yeah
absolutely and every single one of these
can make it here but uh big shout outs
once again in to the family over at
Astro the official headset and the mix
app here at the Tekken online challenge
2021 uh they've been supporting a bunch
of events in the fgc so big shout outs
to them for showing their love here for
us at Tekken online Challenge and I'm
just I can't wait to see what what kind
of characters what kind of matches we're
going to get coming up here uh I mean
obvious I was not ready we saw we
started with the Gan R in in South
America I was not ready for that man so
here I think our our next match I I
think we're going to get crew versus
sery you can see on the bottom there so
I think that means we're going to get
kazuya versus Raven
That's you never see Raven that much you
know like we saw a little bit of uh like
paa and tison coming out of Japan with
the master Raven but uh Raven's not that
very popular you know as a character
Choice it's cuz I feels like she's
difficult to play at a at a in a
tournament level but she's so good as a
character overall mhm I think the the
the strongest strength of that character
for me whenever I play her is that if
you could get the formula just right you
get the launch and then you use your
screw and then you get the wall carry
just perfectly so you can get that back
to double lift launcher at the wall it
does so much damage and it's so
satisfying just seeing their whole life
bar be a chunk of bread you know it's
easily the most satisfying combos to do
cuz cuz number one that combo has her
wall combo has not changed since when
she was just the Reg reg Raven in
5.0 that combo was always the same it
was like if the wall combo just changed
now just add some more hits beforehand
it's cool yeah it's super sick and then
also like her wall carry in general is
just so so much fun to pull off and if
you can get the formula just right so
you can you can set up that back turn
three plus four the damage pays off in
numbers and I think uh out of all the
regular quarle forward crou stash
characters she has the fastest one so a
lot of times you see Raven players doing
like audo wave dash of their own and
they also have a full Crouch slide
Crouch Dash as well so mixed in with
that and the full Crouch one rven is
super explosive in the movement
Department yeah but obviously Sergi's
just as explosive too we've seen his
back dash into electric right so he's
got those too and honestly in this match
up right like s you knowing sergy he's
going for those you know 14 13 frame
electrics right as punishes Master
Raven's not the cleanest character in
terms of that either right she has a lot
ofus 14s and few you know minus 13s her
lows can get launched in this match up
too so she's going to have to be a
little a little patient here yeah cuz T
is going to be very good for Ravens down
back four and down four saving the wall
for the hell s still going to have the
screw as well didn't work out if that
combo had hit I would have been I know I
feel like it was styling that that was
100% on purpose at this point he's man
he's managed to use every neutral punch
or neutral kick in every combo so far
wow didn't okay he got the side switch
but the side wall and the raving first
you know when you find yourself in back
turn for no reason sometimes like that's
the true TP of a raven player right to
get yourself out of there safely and the
sery combos bro show us my man has
showed us a new combo every single
launch
no rerun no rerun episodes around here
dude every episode is brand new even the
Filler episodes are
new Zury technician right now oh my God
crew there's the
chance yeah this is big too he carried
to the wall get a ton of damage going to
get the big perfectly oh no could have
tack that yeah didn't didn't opt to try
to rewall Splat and that's what we were
talking about all of Raven lows like
that other than like down three down
four and down back four are going to get
twin pisted and launched yeah definitely
something you got to be worried worried
about there if your
crew Ser right now down oh he went for
the launch on that yeah he did sery you
know obviously just playing so
comfortable right now feels like he
feels like he's in his
element he even tried to get Max damage
on that wall combo yeah that would have
been sick I was liking the combo Choice
there oh
okay saving himself a back turn with the
back turn jab get Circle forward four
big opportunity not going to be able to
reach the wall just like CL for the wall
carry though like it both players just
out of range nice punish wow that was
beautiful yeah one of one of the nice
things about master her W punish game is
pretty pretty strong she has a lot of
far ranging damn that was yeah great D
you got to be worried of that got the
wall too and the extra damage what Yi
here hell
sweep another hell sweep here could be
bad news that's I know oh God that's why
they both kind of thre CR
oh oh that was counter hit he
Rock oh sery Relentless with the lows he
did triple low at the end he's just like
just die die see that's that's sergy and
that's a kazuya player right because he
went he he recognized he need the low
the the lowest to win but he didn't go
for like down back four down back three
he didn't go for like real kazuya
because he went for generic down down
fours because those moves are almost
like a key to Mishima play right generic
down four is such a pivotal kazuya or
Mishima move and so he utilized it
perfectly he knew that I don't I don't
need to throw these power hits I just
need to get these quick low pokes in to
get the win and man it just felt like ah
there's so many opportunities for crew
to even like get some combos in right he
had a lot of counter hits but just the
the mid-range game he just kept getting
getting beat to the punch a lot of
unfortunate stuff that happened for crew
too he got a lot of opportunities but
then sidewalls kept messing it up or the
Wall came into a weird spot you know
that's like the hard part about Raven
right just figuring out the right
formula to get them to the wall just
right just right so you can set up that
wall combo yeah and even if you do
sometimes just feels like H maybe I
shouldn't even go for it you know I
might I might drop it here you know
that's the reason why we saw he did get
to the wall combo right crew did but he
didn't opt to go for the back turn re
wall Splat right he just said I'm going
finish the walk com I know I can get Max
damage here or good damage here right so
he opted to go for that still got the
kill but one of those things where it's
like yeah did drop some com some a
little bit of damage there but it's not
enough for me to be like that cost you
the game it was just enough for me to be
like oh that's kind of worrisome just
because you know when you're Master
Raven you want to get those Max damage
Combos and it's so scary for him to try
to close out the the rounds with Raven
with a low right because there's so many
like just eliminating down four and down
back four by blocking and launching with
kazuya is terrifying right and then if
he's try to oh wait maybe let let me try
to use a safer low with down three or
something but then that doesn't High
crush and then you get popped in the
mouth with a keod electric or something
you know so oo scary choices here scary
choices round we see how how crew uh
adapts here oh adap R straight
into
oh oh my God searing Edge at the wall wo
electric for the carry look at the stop
wow oh my goodness bro hey hey this
guy's not this guy shouldn't be allowed
to be so cool with kazuya no
right dude sery just looking like a
beast right now man my man sergy is
looking so comfortable right now and
this is the same position we saw at evil
right coming out losers bracket but
dudee you give this guy more games to
play with and he just gets faster look
how fast he's moving now crew finds the
34 big launch nice and going to get the
oh just goes for the back
one oh counter do screw no I don't know
what that jab was I didn't know what
that jab was might have been a different
input something else
maybe zy wow two hits
already power hits coming
out oh my God the wave of electrics are
so nice wh with the Vampire KNE this is
what crew needs right he needs to take
advantage of these times where Ser is
kind of feeling himself right kind of
being a little bit too too aggressive in
that mid-range he's got to find the
whiff punishes but W good back s oh got
a little greedy for the
slide he might be paying for it and the
wall kill top 10 worst ways to die oh no
he just turned her into a a fireball
dude just smacked her into the wall do
fireball out
there oh my
God nice big launch here big opportunity
crew just short of the wall yeah just
got there too but wasn't going to be
able to get too many hits after that got
the get a KCK though
there get the wall yes sir unfortunate
for crew oh she stuck she stuck
unnecessary he tried to power his way
out and traded though no devil for at
the back swing is good crew still alive
he's fighting for his life out here yeah
serg's definitely trying to trying to
style on him a little bit can be a
little risky to go for those back turn
setups too especially against Master
Raven who does have a back turn stance
out of some counters and things like
that out of that too big counter hit big
counter hit combos man these combos are
making me mad cuz I keep thinking
they're all drops right I heard the gasp
in your voice where he held your breath
like did he drop it yeah then I saw the
rest of it like that's about to drop off
oh oh dude sery those are so cool damn
sery too strong man I love the I love
the wall carries that he does where he
just needs one more hit before the wall
and he does like electric standing or
yeah while standing one or the back
three like we just saw there I really
love those and gets the grounded it down
for one after sery still in it man still
in it on the loser side over crew I mean
listen the where you watch sery play you
can immediately tell that this guyy is a
kazuya player like there's nothing about
it that tells me that oh he's a kazuya
player only because you know he likes
this match up or any like no he's a
kazuya player through and through
everything he's doing is like built up
you know a muscle memory kazuya St
status right and like God and every
every launch it feels like all right
what string does the chat want to
see what Str do they want to see any
move request chat c is taking move
request right now you'll fill them into
a combo somewhere it is tight dud I it's
making me mad because I didn't realize
how many bunk kazuya combos existed and
now they all still work they all
work I love the gasp I heard after the
down forward to it's just
like Okay no Okay okay I gassed because
I was like all right is he going to do
electric and then he didn't do electric
I was like oh he's going to whiff and
then this comb was going to drop and
then I recognized what the what the
whiff was like oh he's going to actually
hit him still yeah coming up next as you
guys can see we have sha question mark
going up against Zito and then after
that we're going to be jumping back into
the winner side with AEL going up
against Noel Abel versus Noel sha versus
sapito very excited here we did see sha
earlier and the with the Fang right but
and sapito with the Lei so we're
probably gonna see that match
interesting interesting matchups here
you know uh pretty interesting to see
Fang now you know used so much more
recently you know than ever right it
felt like Fang was the the first season
right where we saw NE use them a lot in
tournament and then after that it it was
like fell off the face of the Earth
never saw him again since that back
cample ner Nerf Nerf right I mean it's
still freaking great but uh ever since
that we haven't really seen Fang too
much but ever since then I felt like
season 3 and four like getting the the
the Buffs that he got are the best kind
of Buffs I I was going to use down back
38 anyways and now it gives me a counter
hit knock like great why not I was going
to use shoulder anyways and now it does
three more damage fantastic yeah what
the hell yeah those are the best kind of
Buffs honestly the ones was like I was
already using this move and you guys
made it better sweet
yeah dang but yeah I I really liked uh I
really like both players play styles
with their characters bad uh Shia with
the Fang just playing really slippery
back kmo back swing blows back back ones
up forward twos forward four forward
four back turn just like just making
that neutral spacing just really hard to
commit to come in on Fang but also seito
too he plays that he kind of plays that
range too with the Le where he's just
like playing around with his back turn
and then he goes for tip range back turn
down four and then his animal start
stances start coming out and stuff so
I'm really interested to see this match
up too thought to be a really good one
it's a Tekken five intro song freaking
uh match
up they both need to just go in the back
turn immediately and just play from
there yes yes go to back turn both of
them and both go for sweet why not why
not just straight up both both of you
guys just go back turn right off the rip
and then just stand
there that'd be so sick that' be so sick
oh here we go though confli once again
yeah plane comes real close I know a
combat is on seven and Tekken is on
seven seven seven seven whoa fight
oh only one it is only one
person all right aito getting this
launch getting get this wall break
too immediately to the new part of the
stage wow for forward yep does make the
second hit wh very good awareness there
oh the snake bite snake Bight oh the
back turned down back both these
characters are going to be able to use
that
technique as we're seeing there yeah but
Zito just you he recognized look I don't
need to push it right I'm I got the lead
so he just back dashed his way and got
the easy Victory there and I love the
move choice too the razor rush to check
all this evasive stuff from Fang because
it's like you could add you could just
do two razor rushes you can do four
catches the back Temple there great
choices here by sapito yeah sapito's
looking real real strong right now and
just the pressure right Shia canot seem
to get Block pun
for Max ball carry just pushing him away
from the wall 5050 put himself airborne
and he gets theion got it yo that was
sick double shoulder but one of them
didn't hit grounded but he's still going
to get the win
nobody Y and he went from back s blow he
went from far enough it wasn't far
enough The Fish Hook still got there
that's that is impressive that the fish
shook a all moves got right cuz it
doesn't have that much range no it's a
great homing attack but the thing is
that you got to be right up in the face
to get that to hit but apparently not C
oh no but the ax is not going to work
out try to save it oh still got to
launch though and it's going to be
regular axis this time so he's going to
get full wall combo setting up crane
oi got
yep nice
Bish and he's going to get the wall and
round with that great stuff by Sha there
man Shia look look a little little leak
there now already he's got the leak I'm
already sad that I'm not going to be
able to see one one of these guys
continue on in the tournament I'm like
already sad cuz I'm loving this right
now sapito fighting back though all back
blow return to favor
no oh the haha steps coming out not down
spin that was godl and that was from
downtown that hit from the tippy tip oh
I was just going to do this anyway
oh man back to the neutral space though
I think that was a shoulder attemp on
the punish oh no uh oh oh no oh no we're
gonna miss the end of that match oh
no oh man I don't know if it was a
disconnect or I hope that they're still
playing it out we oh okay back we just
lost one host we got some backup though
I hope the backup Works we're trying to
bring it back for you guys we're trying
to save the backup oh we tried we tried
we tried Dam unfortunate but as long as
uh their matches weren't disconnected
hopefully we can get back in there for
game number two but that is something
that happens sometimes guys due to the
nature of the online tournaments but uh
yeah man I'm so sad I want to see more
of these guys and ah I mean now we got
to figure out we don't even know if
they're going to who won that first game
and it's going to be
uh close final round of the first game
and I I've been loving the way that
they're approach like just the way that
zedo they're like okay sha mid-range
forward four back cample all this
slipperiness right but I love sedo's
answer there he he checks with razor
rush and the fact that he could just
check with two or if he can do the two
more if he needs it and it's just like
that that forward for into back turn
slipperiness is not going to be as
perspective when razor Rush is coming at
you so I really love that neutral from
both of them I mean the way the way it
looked like it looked like seito kind of
when he had the offense going like it
was real real quick right but it also
felt the other the same same way right
the other way where sh got the offense
and we got one clean Block in right then
that's when all the offense started
going for him so definitely a lot more
uh like you know swinging swinging this
from both players right it feels like
whoever got the offense going is winning
yeah but I
really from what I heard Shia won the
first game
wow hopefully hopefully we can get a
confirmation on that but it's looking
like right now we're going to have our
next match one zero up for Shia wow wow
man I'm just a little sad that we're not
going to get to see more of them man
it's been so good it's been so good so
sh it looks like we we're waiting for a
double confirmation we got to double
check it but from what we're hearing it
sounds like sha has taken the first game
so they're going to be going into game
number two with Shia up
one hopefully hopefully we can get in
that match pretty soon here for you guys
obviously the Fang versus Lei uh you
know we do know sepo does have other
characters but right now I think Lei is
the main I and honestly I loved his lay
right his lay looks so so so nice right
look he looks very comfortable with the
character looks like he knows what he's
doing there but xia you know in that
first first round it made almost made it
feel like man he's not he might not be
in it right but H just he fought back
and he fought his ass off and just ended
up winning those rounds to to make those
comebacks and like you said right down
back three getting that one buff the
counter hit buff is so funny because
it's like yeah cool extra damage I'm in
at a knockdown why not like shoot let me
get those for every charact like those
are honestly the best Buffs man because
damage Buffs I was going to use it
anyway oh it's counter a knockdown or a
counter a launch now oh great I was
going to use it anyways it's like thank
you d d
yeah F got a lot of those a lot of those
and I think that's kind of what has been
an issue with uh not even just Tekken
seventh bang right he's kind of been
historically famous for having really
bad combo damage and that's kind of not
an issue anymore and also in Tekken 7
earlier versions too Fang kind of
suffered from not having that much combo
variety but just that new change with
that down forward for three being a
screw attack and the other variation to
the down forward for two up too but wall
carry helps out Fang so much so much
yeah I mean he definitely needed some of
those some of those like quality of life
Buffs right like and I don't say he
might not have needed it but the damage
Buffs were nice because now you know
obviously you see more in tournament now
before you know didn't really see him
all that much and it's just because you
know all they really did was like all
right he's good he's a good character he
just doesn't do enough damage does boost
up his damage a little bit and then boom
now all of a sudden everyone's a Fang
main again and that new screw helped him
so much just for like combo variety and
just like freestyling for wall distances
too really easy to gauge out like okay I
just need that move get the wall there
and man B it's B yeah B's really I think
in a good spot right now in this current
version of like all of P issues are no
longer issues I think his only oh his
only issue is that he has too many good
moves yeah what kind of what kind of
what kind of issue is that I know right
DJ K suffering from
[Laughter]
success oh yeah but it seems like we're
still waiting to see if we can get the
the next match underway between these
guys uh we just had it seems like they
were able to play out the match but uh
yeah we weren't able to get the last bit
of the round on stream so hopefully we
can get that underway for you guys very
soon very
soon oh man so I'm excited to see what
else we got here though I mean the
winner side final is going to be pretty
interesting we got you know we got your
your boy Steve Fox in there with Noel
and versus Abel who probably I wonder
what character would you think he's I
was that's what I was wondering too
because I'm
like I feel like Steve versus Eddie such
a traditional matchup now because it's
just been around for so long that I I
figure that AEL is probably pretty
comfortable with that right but also at
the same time is there any extra
strengths that Eliza can utilize in that
matchup uh and I'm kind of thinking
about it and it's like whenever I play
sukin Eliza a I really hate the jump
back but then I think that's just like
her versus anybody so yeah I'm not yeah
I'm not too sure I'm not too sure I
think I think he might just run the
Eddie just for the Legacy match up
that's what I would think too right the
the Legacy but it's also one of those
things where it's like it's he almost
feels like his his Eliza is like his
tournament character now right like I
feel like he feels the most comfortable
and it feels like that way with a lot of
players too right but Junior finally has
kind of settled down it's really an
Eliza main now and it's working out for
him you know I almost think like that's
kind of where Chanel's headed to as well
where Eliza's still like the main
character even though he's Al Lisa and
you know Julia and
Zina around all over the place yeah but
then he within every other week he's
posting like another quadruple dive kick
Eliza combo clip and I'm like he spends
a lot of time on her
he yeah he definitely still likes that
character no way he doesn't finding
infinites on Bears on backr wall Splats
and oh man she's got some juice right
cuz uh you know I think we're in a very
interesting time right now where yeah
Eliza has been around since like release
of the game right but now we're kind of
seeing the the the later DLC characters
get a little bit more flushed out we're
seeing the Lydia more uh from like the
Asia region as well we're seeing the COI
mitsu more as well uh and it's really
fun to watch uh like different takes on
these characters and just see how
different drivers to handle them and
stuff you know it's been really fun yeah
okay uh so we're gonna go to a quick
break real quick just to make sure that
we can get this next match settled for
you guys so don't go anywhere we'll be
right back uh stay
[Music]
tuned
yeah
[Music]
you
I
[Music]
you
am
I
[Music]
we
yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
not
[Music]
w
all right welcome back guys this is the
Tekken online challenge Master's event
for 2021 and we are here in the South
America region you guys are joining with
me NYK and ricka as my co- commentator
and uh unfor fortunately we weren't able
to see the end of the match and then the
set ended up going down to uh sha taking
it over sapito so it ended up being a 20
we heard that sapito actually switched
to Ling in game number two but wasn't
able to close it out and we're going to
be moving on into the winnner finals
it's going to be Abel going up against
Noel you like that huh
yeah a bill or or Noel I mean it's going
to be I think we're going to get what uh
the Eddie or Eliza versus the Steve Fox
I man I hope they both bring out just
random characters Kuma versus uh geese
that'll make us happy oh I need my I
need my mandatory back ons and my
counter it down for twos and all that I
need those man I believe that's going to
be our next match yep and then the last
match of the day or not the last match
sorry but the last match of top four was
going to be Sergey versus sha also the
this is able versus versus Noel is the
Winner's final so that's going to be
first to three but uh the other match
sery versus sha is only a first to two
yeah that should be the last first of
two for the rest of the tournament uh
yeah the winners finals going to be
first of three losers finals and Grand
finals as well and if you guys aren't
too familiar with the tournament formats
it's a dumble elimination tournament so
that means whoever's coming from the
loser side if they want to take the
whole thing is going to need to reset
that first set to send the Winner's
opponent to the losers bracket to get
the reset and close it out from there
but yeah it's not impossible we have
seen many players do it before Seri also
in the losers uh side right now in the
top four and we saw him do do the exact
same thing from there at Evo so
definitely not impossible and it was
against someone that's on the winner
side of the bracket too in AB Bel demro
as well so a a lot of familiar faces
here but right now AB Bel demro I think
is in the comfortable side on the winner
side obviously but he does have a tough
task ahead of him in the well uh just
interesting you know because we did see
the Steve Fox and it and it seemed to
work out really well so just you know
you and like we talked about earlier
you're the Steve Fox player here you uh
you didn't seem to be too confident in
the Eliza match up per se right you you
felt more about the you f you felt that
he would go forel would go more for the
Eddie just for the safe pick right
exactly it's a classic matchup and I'm
sure uh Noel definitely knows it uh
fighting if you if you play teking for a
while you definitely ran into a couple
Eddy here and there but then you know
like the 2D characters that we have
nowadays with like Eliza G auma uh I
mean Eliza kind of came from the Tekken
background but she shares a lot of the
same similari she has the the 2D style
jump and the ex moves and then the
special moves and especially the the
most useful part about Eliza's backwards
jump compared to the other two is that
she could come in forward with the ex
side kick so anytime she gets an evasive
back jump she could punish you for
trying to overextend any any kind of
commitment but there yeah it's one of
those tough ones like but the jump back
creates her own back dash you know
that's what easy the easy Whi punish is
just the ex dive kick right so it
becomes a very easy whiff punish but at
the same time it's kind of predictable
too so you got you can't be too like oh
I want to jump back I think I saw him
whiff something cuz you can you can
definitely get banded into things like
that as well but uh you know Abel is a
very smart player I'm curious see which
character he'll go with against the
Steve Fox specifically because you know
it seems like a tough match up right for
I would say probably for Eddie more so
than Eliza but I don't know it just
seems both of those matchups just seem
odd to me like it doesn't seem like a
very fun matchup regardless yeah st's a
very hard character to go up against
because he's just so darn safe like
everything he does is just super safe
the openings are hard to find but as we
can see here we're going with the Eliza
pick and we got the island paradise off
the random stage select let's go yeah
we'll see if he how he can utilize the
walls obviously Alli are very very
strong with walls Steve also strong with
walls but not necessarily A NE uh
necessity for him you know he doesn't
need the walls neither does Eliza so
much but the way he plays Eliza he can
definitely utilize all of the wall
techniques there classic Steve outfit as
well i' love to see it starting it off
right away with the
442 oh going straight away into the
slaps
okay nice gets the punish on the Cal
back one
oh got the
counter love the way that both these
guys are playing right now the movement
from both players good steps from Noel
punishes the down forward to duck ccel
in his
face
oh KO
nice
oh very common spot where you'll see
steeve players go for the back one
flicker one down one is is zero on block
so if you try to Mid check Steve the
back one will trade a lot of
times Abell with the combo though oh
he's trying to keep that wall pressure
man the down jab used from Abel is so
good especially with this
Eliza I love the way that Noel's using
these weaves to try to get away from
Eliza's pokes oh but got caught yeah the
running slide works out one a
piece oh those fireballs and that dark
wave one that's kind like the bait it's
just like try to punish my Fireball I
dare you it's still right there in front
of me uses the ex gets the free Moon
Glide cancel off of it as well doesn't
work out with the mid Choice another
counter hit back one Ohi har man you
weren't kidding about those sways too
those was definitely helping
out pushing the wall a lot of these
pokes making a lot of things a lot less
threatening down jab challenge right
away side to down forward four doubles
up wanted this time the low gets the
pick up comble time he's right back in
it for pressure down jab ex Fireball
conversion not enough oh no well with a
great counter poke with the down forward
one I'm not sure how easy it is to
convert off of that either AB Bel did
have rage but I once you go into that
Moon Glide I don't know how easy it is
to stop the moon Glide and get a rage
are and still hope that it hits right
man Noel playing great right here nice
every wh not going unpunished that was a
great low Parry there from Abel de mro
though going to break this wall oh uh oh
oh
no oh is it
oh all this good ass Tekken a damn man
we want it to work just as much as you
guys do to obviously but yeah we
do yeah hopefully we can get it situated
we do have a couple other host guests
and stuff that we could hopefully pull
into the match but if not we're going to
have to wait for the next one Dam ah man
it sucks because you know obviously I
want to see how the how that match plays
out too right cuz I mean South America
has some Killers obviously so it's like
I want to see how these matches play out
but you know sometimes just we just
haven't got the connection yet so
hopefully we can get that squared up for
you guys real quick you know obviously
we you you know we know you guys want
watch it we want to watch it too so
that's what we're here for yeah
absolutely and man the set was going so
well like as a Steve player Noel's
hitting all the back ones like how can I
not be happy man like dude he's finding
every back one that he needs and things
are going great but A's putting up a
fight he's bringing it down to final
round and then uh he got the combo and
then we just got frozen in time man we
got time stop dang that's how it be man
and I really love uh I've been really
loving the way that uh both the
characters that we saw right there their
walk game their lows get way scarier
when your back's against the wall right
and then and then Noel knows that so
he's using a lot of the weaves to get
around the down three a lot of those
options like that and the small pokes
and then that's been really working out
for Noel but Bell man just just biting
it out and a lot of things working out
but Frozen a time yeah
it's hard it's hard to know who who's
feeling down right now right like
hopefully that game if that game did
finish we'll we'll know like who's
feeling like kind of cornered right now
but cuz you know at the at because we we
know for sure at least Abel does have
another character we don't know so much
about Noel if he's just a Steve only
player or if he you know likes to play
other characters but the Steve obviously
looking super strong here so I don't I
wouldn't really be too shocked if
something changed here oh yes and we are
back in it for game number two we don't
know the score yet we'll see it as as
soon as you guys see it
too no character switches or nothing
same old same old we're just going to go
into the random stage select we're
getting Kinder JY and looks like game
number one actually went to Noel wow all
right so big win there that's a that's a
huge first game
there got didn't get a character switch
out of a bell or stage select either you
know a b Bel very must be old school
yeah that's the most old school method
right there dark way just random select
it's
tournament oh get the back one of his
own back one boys yeah B's been hitting
those back one twos and a lot of times
do even feel like they're counter hit
right they just hit on the
high just ping with the down two one
just couple little low poke chip oh
wasn't in range but didn't get the duck
on the high Sonic Fang block didn't get
punished rocket launcher wall pressure
Noel just trying to step with AEL trying
to keep his back against the the
wall the Fireballs forcing Noel to step
two and Noel uses that to get him off
the wall I'm liking AB Bill's use of the
Crouch mixup right doing a lot of w 92s
mixing up with the down threes getting
the W the duck and that method right
there too is going to just naturally
evade back one finds the for four2 knock
down blockable shoulder plus frames
doubles up backs
away 5 seconds left reload fors and it's
enough what wow I can't believe I can't
believe he let him get away with that
though Bel like play patient but a
little bit too patient let noell back in
it and that oh my God three hits damage
though didn't get too much off of it but
he has a full stick of butter against
low off the low uh off the down jab no
with another chance here but Eliza was
just a jab punish she's willing to burn
as she can kill doesn't matter she used
it there for the free Moon
Glide nice punish
low Parry again the Well's low Perry
timing has been on point going to get
Max
damage oh wake up ex DP no Splat no
Splat oh break down Jeff getting under
the wall sing one one aell fighting
fighting Moon Line mid I Bell does love
his down Jabs right it's so good for him
too especially for this
character but yeah Noel man like signs
of a great Steve Fox is the low pares
man and he's getting all of them yeah
very patient but still oh my God taking
the right risk oh he could have got one
more
oh Shin blade
725 just the one though not not even the
second he went for the rocket punch
after oh dive kick pressure at the wall
dive kick pressure wow look at the way
he safely w 8 them but the Ford Ford
for2 finds his Mark Abel takes the lead
in the game number two but you said
something about Noel getting that 180
right but that was because Abel he
stopped attacking after dive kicks CU he
recognized Noel kept stepping him so he
didn't want to push his pressure yeah I
love the way Noel is just always
fighting for the wall positioning too
shoulder gets gets oh my God that linked
dang that was good tiger need freaking
dive kick as low as possible to the
floor so you can get that jab into ex
light that that was that was clean yeah
if right to the wall too he Abel
definitely knew everything about that
situation he knew that the the dive kick
was going to hit low enough so the jab
comboed into the ex into the wall like
everything there was so calculated so
smart so nice shot from Abel and two
right and you said ear like about how
like Noel was able to side step out of
it right and that was just because of
how uh Abel stopped attack you have to
dive kick because the the thing is that
Abel's dive kick pressure is usually so
so strong but Noel neutralized that
pretty hard in game one right we saw a
lot of the sways and the side stepping
and so you know things like like a dive
kick into a jab gets easily stuffed by
just one step so that's the reason why
you saw a bell he would dive kick and
just wait and just see what happens and
just kind of let let the situation play
out but then yeah like right there when
Abel used the dive kick to get the
jabing that's where it's super scary
right when you're you're knocked down
your Tech roll you're forced to guess a
mixup and Eliza if she does that tiger
knee dive kick right there it's a mid
it's a true mid on that one and man that
that combles into like a bunch of stuff
dude it's it's scary scary yeah I mean
and obviously against the bell too who's
you know is going to have his combos on
lock he's going to have the the right
you know reads there the right
predictions to to make sure he gets
maximum damage I mean that was so nice
too no you know what the funny thing too
is that it feels like like he's getting
a lot of these big hits but not off like
a lot of counter hits either right it
feels like just a lot of just very smart
technical plays and especially even from
Noel's side too Noel's like as soon as
his back's to the wall he's like well
Low's are scary I don't want to block a
low because if I block I still have to
block whatever he's cancelling into so
let me just cut out the middleman let me
just low parry and let me get my damage
in you know so he's just already
defensively he's like I'm changing it up
low Parry low Perry low Perry yeah and
you know honestly as a Steve player
myself low Perry I think is the
preferred uh low defense for Steve
because like that a was standing one two
hurts but the low par combo hurts more
and you can get a wall combo if you get
the wall yeah so so yeah like getting
good low per re and Noel's been getting
almost all of them man so that's been a
wild but Abel answering back here we go
game number three
now tied up one1 here we got the Mishima
Dojo though oh did he counter hit the
down two that looked like down two oh
whatever counted it right off the
rip oh no a Bill's feeling
good that kick so scary and this time
Abel like Ricky said yeah waited it out
oh he did the one Fireball the W sending
one two got there before it became
active but doesn't even matter and
that's risky too challenging down three
as soon as you block it she could just
cancel into different special moves
oh here comes the dive kick pressure
again but look at Noel just side step
block side step block so he can't
continue that dive kick pressure like
that yeah he keeps like he wants to too
but Noel's movement outside of it is
just he's willing to play defensively
but still AB Bell getting the ex meter
spent there going to get the wall combo
too where you
going oh this is scary this is scary
wall
position jump away ex dive kick that we
talked about such a good tool it's like
you know Steve right there wanted to
take his turn back take the rage drive
hit or block doesn't matter he wanted
that turn but she wasn't there she was
out of there yeah she jumped backwards
into the walls class 2D counter player
in the corner you got to jump
backwards right jump in the corner
that's such a 2d thing
right just backing fourth right now wow
but it
trades yeah we've been seeing a lot of
challenges from Noel from like a bunch
of these special cancel points in
Eliza's offense and right there aell
made a pay off R Drive is good but wall
angle is
weird yeah oh my God what is going on
yep yep you know what happened right
there I think Noel the way that Steve
Fox turned around there that's actually
like a like a weird glitch right where
Steve you know how he could Fox step
Albatross when he's back back turn mhm
but he was the game registered him like
as if he was turning around so it gave
him like a half ALR weed thing and he
turned around got hit and that's exactly
what happened right there with Steve
definitely one of those weird situations
where you got to pay attention I mean
like we saw it earlier too with Master
Raven right when we saw Master Raven was
in back turn and you know like if you're
if you're not a regular Master Raven
player or if you're not playing a
character that's in back turn regularly
it's weird because you have to kind of
know that you're in back turn
even if they Tech right if they Tech
that means they put you in the back turn
stance even though you didn't want to be
there so now you got to kind of all
right let me get out of back turn in
order to block safely and a lot of times
you know players especially if they're
not used to the play the character it's
like I'm back turn well I'm
dead yeah that definitely happens a lot
with Master Raven and yeah that's the
true test of a being a real master Raven
main or not are you going to go for the
Parry are you going to go for the punch
counter are you going to go for the the
power Crush when you're in those funky
scenarios and as a Steve player too like
oh funky backward scenario I'm going to
go for the I'm going to go for the
albatross but then the game said no you
know it happens it definitely does
happen yeah I think we're going to take
another small break real quick though so
sorry about that but we got to try to
get these technical issues fixed just
real quick so don't go anywhere guys
we'll be right
back
[Music]
oh
you
[Music]
h
the
one
[Music]
w
the
one
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the Tekken
online challenge 2021 South America my
name is ricka that's myk and uh
obviously we are in the middle of a
Winner's final set we just had to get
some technical things straightened out
but I think we are back into it uh from
what I remember I believe the set is
still 1 one right so it's still in the
middle of the set
uh I think so maybe Noel got 2 one but I
I don't remember
yeah we'll get everything squared out
here but we do have the set ready I
think they're still in the lobby about
ready to play so uh excited to see how
this how this sets up because you know
it's a close set still right we got the
Liza versus the Steve match up going on
strong here uh excited to see how this
plays out yeah it's been going great so
far both of these guys are duking it out
and I love the counterplay from both
players but man it's it's really whoever
could get them to the wall first but
then the way that Noel has been working
his way around the wall too has been
like super impressive for me just like
taking the little side steps little side
step blocks just to kind of 180 the wall
position back to aell but man here we go
forgotten realm stage and uh I think
Eliza kind of ever since they changed uh
oh it's actually 2-1 in the bell's favor
nice so we're going to the Forgotten
realm stage and Eliza ever since they
changed her die kick three no longer
floor breaks anymore so I think her wall
her floor break combos kind of got
shafted in the the later versions
neither of these characters seem to have
like crazy uh floor break things though
right I'm not sure if Steve really gets
a opportunity to use it that much Steve
has like two very good ones on this one
uh he gets down back 32 down back three
at the walls and he gets a mini combo
off of that off the low or in the open
Steve can also do duck one into forward
forward two which is a natural combo and
leads into the floor break into a full
combo downstairs
afterward all here we go the Forgotten
realm here you can see multiple floor
breaks very beautiful stage yeah Triple
Decker floor break stage this was the
only one in Tekken 7 for a while and it
was funny that they stacked all three in
one
stage oh gets the counter it down for
two and the pickup we're going for the
FL break saves it he tried to for the
wall yeah yeah that Sonic Fang right
there at the wall you try to wall
carry Che the frames nice duck on the
high wow Noel's just so sharp round
two
fight nice pokes there from Mel trying
to counter poke his way out you know
funny thing is that even though he's
going up against Steve right he's
ducking a lot because he's so scared of
that back one
mhm gets the wall perfectly there and
the floor break nice amount of damage
there going to break the floor
too good movement around the Fireballs
just trying to find an opening he has
the perfect wall positioning here Noel's
just so good at maintaining this wall
pressure but Abel just rearranging
it a instant peekaboo launcher out of
nowhere didn't get the punish really
hard gets the wall bounce and the right
pick up no he could Pro oh no oh over
committed for the low option there Abel
takes it he could have broke the floor
there into like a rard or something
right there's a lot of options he had
there but yeah he went for flicker one
one down one which is the screw he could
have went for forward one which would
have been the for break yeah ooh and the
return to favor low
Parry all right going to the wall carry
nice yeah and if I'm a bell here I would
just try to use a ball as possible don't
even give Steve the chance to use it all
right I mean whenever you get the
opportunity to no matter what character
you're playing I would suggest going for
unless you can get the kill drops the
dive kick ex dive kick okay doesn't bite
on the ex Fireball though but finds the
homing
attack oh rage Drive expended wall
pressure gets the foot
stomp nice block and the ex to do more
damage after the down Jab great
calculations there by Abel that was
crazy I never even thought about that
yeah that's so smart cuz he knew that
the regular DP wasn't going to be enough
and the ex was going to do it that was
so smart got the link he is impressive
when it comes that punish final chance
for Noel and that's going to be it AEL
makes it into the grand finals 3 to one
over Noel yeah you know it's kind of a
kind of the spot that we would
anticipate Abel being in right obviously
he's one of the best players out of
South America out of Peru obviously you
know one of the best players in the
world right and so for him to be in the
grand finals is kind of expected but at
the same time you know he's always had
some had some trouble with the with this
local competition so you know to for him
to be able to make it out and to make it
to Grand finals here uh pretty big
showing for him right and it was pretty
close to but it was able to get get it
there uh Noel going to the losers side
losers finals however top three so still
in it but obviously a hard road ahead
yeah definitely that losers finals
though going to be another first to
three but the next match coming up is
going to be our final first to two we're
going to take a look at the bracket once
again and it's going to be stury Master
going up against sha in the loser semis
and the winner of that is going to be
going up against Noel in the losers
finals yeah very very close matches here
very good matches coming up sha versus
Sergei is going to be the next one I
assume that's going to be Fang versus
kazuya uh I know you know obviously so
you know we've commentated plenty of
sery sergey's matches in the past and
you know currently but every time he
plays he makes new fans and it's
guaranteed it's guaranteed like I I see
in the chat I saw in the chat room
people were like Sergey is the best
coolest kazuya ever you know like all
all this praise right and that's what
get that's what playing kazuya does and
this is this is my this is my TED Talk
for all you aspiring kazuya Ms you could
be like Sergey you could hella have fans
if you're good and dope and can do cool
stuff D you might as well put the
umbrella around all the Mishima players
you know it's like hey man you want to
be a cool Mishima player play kazuya
stop messing around with devil genin no
no if I'm telling people they want if
they want to win they'll play devil
genin yeah I know for real you want if
you want to be cool as hell if you want
to win in the game just play devil genin
but if you want to win our hearts play
Kazo and you could also win the
tournament too cuz I mean serg's good
enough to win these tournaments too
that's that is the most impressive part
right cuz at least for for for kazuya
scrubs like myself right watching a a
good kazuya player like you know with
all the execution and stuff and yet they
still lose it's like that's common like
we see that all the time it's like oh
yeah you know that guy has crazy
kazuya that's been the joke for a while
right it's just like oh here we go round
star counter it down 4ward two hey they
got the electric hey they even got the
four electrics into screw they have a
and then they got the wall too they have
a 90% lead and then they end up losing
the round I'm just like how do you lose
the round after you had a 90% lead I
don't it happens all the time though
with most common kazas you know that's
that's the Kaz that's the kazuya thing
right but that's the reason why Sergey
is so impressive because he's doing
these sick things he's he's dropping
he's dropping just random strings and
combos like you know let me see if this
this string Works in this com it does
yeah back two one always connects
afterwards you know he's doing all this
cool stuff and yet showing out and still
winning with a character that is you
know Kaz is no let's be honest k is not
a weak character by any means right he's
a very strong character but it's hard to
be good with him in a tournament right
it feels hard to be good with him and
yet Sergey makes it look so good so yeah
he's looking so clean but once again big
shout outs to the Tekken online
challenge we're going to take a look at
the schedule here you guys are checking
out the South America region right now
tomorrow we're going to have the West
Europe region happening week after east
Europe and so on and so forth Mark these
dates down these are the master events
coming up and then we have the regional
finals happening later on in the year in
November going all the way to January
stay tuned for these more Tech con
actions happening for the rest of 2021
yeah if you guys live in any of those
regions as well and want to participate
it's free to enter so just make sure you
can you know find it find the
information online remember those dates
sign up for those tournaments on smash.
DG and uh yeah free tournament stand up
free free you know Tekken to watch free
Tekken to play in man it's fun so you
know make sure to join in uh man and
obviously you get to see all these
different regions right that's why I'm
like like obviously you know because
we've been to South America so many
times like now I've gotten a taste of
South America I know what it's like down
there the Tekken over there it's good
it's good so I want to see I want to see
what the the Tekken tastes like in
Iceland you know Greenland what up
what's the teken taste like over there
you know D when you said little pockets
of like hidden talent that we don't know
I'm dude I'm waiting man what's the next
region like the World Cup of Tekken is
happening now man beautiful thing I just
want to see every country fight
everybody man it's been so much
fun all right uh did I hear that
right okay so we're we got to go to
another break one more time so don't go
anywhere guys we'll be right
back
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
you
he
[Music]
you
all
[Music]
on
yeah
[Music]
n
yeah
[Music]
you
I
yeah
you
[Music]
the
tarnished will soon
return Guided by
Grace once
lost
the golden order is broken to its
[Music]
core foul
tonist
in search of the Elden
ring embolden by the flame of
ambition someone must
extinguish thy
flame they will
fight and they will
die in an un an ending
curse for El is a champion or a lord to
be
born
well
a lowly
tarnished playing as a
lord I command the
n
brandish the Elden
ring for all of
us it's not just our
power it's all of our powers working as
a team don't underestimate me here
goes be prepared for
anything
needi we have to work
[Music]
[Applause]
together
Focus connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the
world you two handle the front while I
take the
back don't bother resisting I will obain
your red
[Music]
strings
pretty fancy place they got here Harmony
and
coexistence between the renin and the
Dann I'm Doh helim ilaris should you
need need my skills on the battlefield
all I care for is maintaining
peace I'm captain kisara of the Elder
men Andia
G flare Demolisher from now on when I
fight I fight to protect my dream well
this crew just gets bigger and
bigger the renin seems the rumors you
were running with them were
true get to see bird
strike been looking for
you h of get the hell out of my realm
this is Ton's realm and it's ours
[Music]
understand is it
over it's only Just
Begun all right guys welcome back this
is the Tekken online challenge Masters
event for the South America region year
in 2021 you guys are joining with me and
my co- commentator ricka and we got to
see some of those amazing game trailers
you know we got uh Scarlet Nexus Tales
of arise Tales of
arise Tales of
Aris I saw that we also have man Elden R
oh I can't wait to be one of the
tarnished but we are here to continue it
off with some good ass teching action
for you guys we're going to be going
into the loser semi battle uh and thank
you guys for hanging around we are ready
to get back into it yes sir but first
things first shout outs to our sponsors
Astro here supporting the they are the
official headset and mix app of the
tanket online challenge 2021 and they've
been supporting us for so long so shout
outs to Astro so much uh and obviously
we are in our top four now I believe
we're going to go to our loser semis uh
between Sergey and uh sha yeah so it's
going to be a pretty interesting one
right there you can see this is the rest
of the bracket here winner this will
play Noel in the losers finals and then
the winner will will be playing AB Bel
demro in the grand finals the
semi-finals however is only a first of
two and then every match after that
every set after that will be a first to
three so this a big one for these
players because even though it's a
losers match and the win loser goes home
they only have two matches right so it's
a so it's less uh less you know less
time to mess around I guess yeah
absolutely right and uh you know it's so
funny with that little question mark at
the end of Shia's name cuz I feel like I
have to honor the question mark and be
like Shia yeah just I mean that's that's
his name his name he his birth
certificate has a question mark at the
end you got to say it like
that you know I'm ready to see it man I
was liking a lot of the stuff that I saw
from his fang but uh man he's got to
play that slippery and loose style while
being able to avoid the hell sweeps the
electrics the 4 43s and all the other
stuff that Ser is going to be throwing
at him so we'll see man is it's no small
fee and also like the game two this is
one of those matchups where kazuya has a
couple of uh Scouts for couple of the
Snipes on the lows whenever he blocks
down back three newly buff down back
three or the the quarle forward one it's
going to be a easy launch for kazuya and
those yeah so we'll see whether or not
sha can uh navigate this problem that
has been sery mat's kazuya but kazuya
you know but serg's in the losers
bracket and you know so obviously he
can't lose two games here neither can sh
we got the mhima Dojo here beautiful
beautiful stage broke the wall open just
so that we could see the moon dude I
don't I didn't even realize all those
symbols on the floor just so many
details in these stages that I didn't
even really get to appreciate before
yeah as soon as someone falls on the
floor all the work is ruined yeah
exactly all that cool stuff that's
written on the floor just turns into
dust oh he thought he got a bigger
punish off of that it was just a stature
kick though oh trades with the electric
the first interaction of
that yeah both of those moves you know
are are are kind of both of their uh
go-to moves right forward four versus
electric oh nice SC three got oh he
tried to fix the angle but didn't get it
SC four finds
home off in yeah I like
that ooh the wave FS coming out of sery
got the throw break and the side switch
he's like I got my electrics and W was
up that might be a punish for the throw
and it is sh KO might have been a
mistake too on Sergey I'm not sure why
he went for a throw there but it wasn't
going to hit and Chow with the clean
whiff punish with the rage art twoo of
all things yeah that was interesting
throw didn't get the screw afterwards it
is a little tight to get nice the block
this time yeah got the big block on that
side set
four big damage there oh my God standard
bread and butter I've ever seen sergy do
he's always like freestyling these
combos once he gets the sing too that's
when he's like Max damage I need Max
damage everything else is like oh
electric oh I a freestyle that was so
sick triple wave electric had to go for
the high Crush to get under it but the
443 finds home because of that yeah Ser
pedal use a
443 no he didn't get it he's got he
didn't turn around yeah the down jab you
was still punching the
wall
oh can't get the Airborne conversion a
big opportunity for sha does the fish
hook to leave himself available to
attack but the down four is going to
beat him out there that was nice from
Shia though I like the way he played
that great that's exactly what I was
talking about so Ry oh look at the
damage
too oh no
duck small punish didn't even get
that side wall saves his life yeah one
traded with the down for two as well
good
block and even the tsunami kicks wow he
was looking for it he almost had it he
tried to chase down the back temple with
the Wu w CAU him with the counter hit
pizza
maker block the back away both players
back to the neutral space back Temple
coming ah one of the issues was being an
electric launcher right a high launcher
doesn't hit the
lowers if your move has a high Crush
frame at the end like how sha did with
that Fang move right there can't with
punish with the electric like that tied
up now 0 0 but two rounds a piece wow
good long windy to wh punish the forward
four that's is that is what he knows him
for wow two to get off the
wall couple generic lows there from
Sergey nice Ste with the flash punch and
get the wall SL with the hell sweep the
angle was just right congrat that's dead
that was that was sick it seems like
every time Serge's doing something it
always feel feels somewhat calculated
right like oh there's a reason he did
this you know it's like that one have
felt like oh he knew the wall was going
to be right there for the perfect
opportunity to get the kill there and
obviously he did it man yeah dude and
then coming coming into it game number
one too is usually where I feel as sery
needs like a couple rounds to start
revving up the fast wus but this game he
just came in swinging man he was he was
loose right out of the gate so but then
you know Shia wasn't playing bad either
but he wasn't no it just just a couple
of those decisions right and it's also a
testament to sergey's defense too his
defense is really on point like whenever
even when xia wants to poke with the low
a lot of the times he blocks it and
launch punishes it and that's terrifying
against K I think that's the one thing
too that I think will oh this is going
to be underrated for most kazuya players
but Seri too because his offense is so
fun to watch right and obviously Kazi
offense in general is fun to watch but
it's his defense that really makes his
offense shine right his his his ability
to even attempt to punish you know minus
15-4 with electric right uh his his with
punishing his movement backwards in
order to open it up and get the punish
forward right so his movement all over
the place his defense has been really
what's opening up his
offense here we go though game number
two sha opting to go to the island
paradise stage it's a really big wall
stage with one balcony break and then
the stage opens up even more but here we
go yeah you know honestly I like this
stage I don't know actually because I
feel like kazuya's wall carry is not
that good yeah but at least that's what
I thought and then sergei's like no I
got wall carry for days man don't worry
about it you know this is on the stage
size for this honestly feels like it
fits the wall carry
now both players uh no I mean I mean
just for the game in general the game in
general I see yeah
yeah all right here we go sha already
off to a good start gets a little flow
conversion but since he put a fish hook
right there in the second hit he's not
going to be able to get too much more
afterward wow counter hit nice the duck
duck goose two lows then the mid goty
there sh just went all in right he even
blocked the hell sweep but just only
pish with lost 91 but it didn't matter
cuz all the pressure that he put on
sergy just W him that round nice gets
the punch on the down for to little
pokes afterward too w
W he used it for the low crush and gets
the uh wall break here we go okaz spin
already yeah
wow bad news for
sery nice confirms The Flash punch just
in
case ah get up kick and sery was so
ready for that
go Hy
y that was so well played calculated
perfectly knew exactly what he need to
do there easy yep that's the easy one
you get the trade there you always go
that electric that Cobble that was
cool oh nice while standing three just
for the
Homing nice double CI delayed it
too now H off from Shia and makes a no
get the
oh blue is expended final chance for
both it's anybody's
game
p yo oh guess the counter d p to this is
a great start for zy not going to be
able to reach the wall that was suppos
SI trade shoulder
yes so clean here for both players oh he
tried to punish the windy committed to
the whole one two two oh you saw right
there he tried to punish with the mid
this time rather than the high nice
punch and the screw this
time no wall though sery uses the blue
so scary that kle always a threat and
also forward four catches of this time
we got a set yep Shia taking it now
tying it up 1-1 ooo man that was close
that was I mean bro the the the round
that sery felt like he was winning the
entire time in was like no all right
forward Kempo let me make sure all right
let me make sure all these hit it's like
everything was so sick the punch Perry
setup worked and even when he was going
for back Kempo oh my God he didn't even
get the whiff yet but he did the Hop
kick in anticipation for a low and he
got it off the statue K like all those
reads like worked out man and that was
ah that was so good that was so good
yeah and I mean you you called it early
too right where Sergey was trying to
rush up and do down for too right to try
to catch a back Kempo the thing is that
sha has Kemp's timing has been so good
because realistically sery hasn't been
able to punish very many of them even on
whiff too right he he saw whiff and you
saw one time he crouched cuz he knew he
saw it was a low and then he wanted to
do something he did w standing one two
which doesn't have great range it's
extremely fast but the range of it is so
bad that you really need to be right in
you need to be kissing them in order to
make that thing hit right so it's it's
not the best punish there so
unfortunately it wasn't going to work
out for him and it also changes it up
too because he can't
wh punish with electric because electric
is high and these moves are crushing
high so yep like like we saw in that
last game down back three recovers
crouching so like against character like
kazuya his best whiff Punisher is a high
and Fang doesn't really have to worry
about that if he whiffs a downback three
but if it gets blocked then kazuya can
easily launch it yeah I mean kazuya can
still launch it on whiff it's just a
little you know you got to be a little
you have to almost dial back the what
you what you know you know CU Kaz man
what you know is electric to punish
everything
especially tag one but man starting it
off with the hell sweep Vortex toe kicks
to get out no no third one no third one
sh was ready for it dude and even being
on offense and defense in that scenario
it's just like two lows than the mid
right the fact that sha still read that
he was going to go for another hell
sweep oh where you going with that up
forward two this is a homing move yeah
the down for two clean counter there oh
the dash up side switch if he broke it I
like the
thinking the back Temple is going to get
himself Corner well terrify and gets
it wow sha in the lead now that was
actually pretty
nice that's the thing about oh my God
this is looking bad for Seri
here huge lead for sha in round number
two
already yeah dude the the way that he
makes it so hard to hit him on the
incoming forward kle two now for the
Parry oh that's guaranteed Jades of tag
one Shades of tag one look at the
damage serg is utilizing the devil form
oh wow he back dashed the last hit of
112 nice sh on set point oh my gosh zy
now nice side step that's that's what he
needs to he needs a character how he
down in the game and he's just like I'm
going to find this I am going to find
this you're kazuya Mains they they're
never scared they're never down that was
sick they're in it or they're dead dude
the way that Shia is mixing up the
pressure punch Perry back kle back swing
blow forward kemple forward for oh my
God it's just too much how do I find my
way in sery does it with the hell
sweeping into the stature yeah I think
that's what Sergi's doing right he's
waiting for shadow whiff and then he's
utilizing his own mix uh his mix right
his Crouch Dash his wave Dash he's
utilizing that to get in to close the
distance so that he can't use backwards
cample step and then he risks it between
the mids and the
lowso getting scary zy going for the
forward three option there long range
mid six out of the 10 tring yeah he's
recognizing that this this mini game
that he's playing from afar he's going
to have to check with the long range mid
but even the mid didn't get there to do
anything wow and sha just playing this
Kempo game
perfectly he's playing with his food a
little bit uhoh uh-oh did he give him
the opportunity he is lucky that sery
does not have rage oh no kind of I kind
of had a feeling dude that was a panic R
sery totally baited it out of him this
is it uhoh man that one forward four
into the back turn Shia might be beating
himself up over that could have got that
was a sus range you know I think that's
why he didn't go for the distance
unfortunate this so crazy 50% lead for
sh you can't whip punish that it's so
hard man he's making it so hard to get
in on him
oh oh he did it it didn't matter sha did
it on purpose he knew that was sick sha
well played going to be moving into the
Winner's final over the Evo champ with
the Fang nice nice stuff yeah I mean
obviously we all love sery right we're
all kazuya fans here but unfortunately
fourth place is not where he wants to
finish his day at but that's where he
will finish his day at sha moves on to
go up against Noel and the run back of
the winners uh semi-finals this time
will'll be a best of three so we'll get
to see that run back between Noel and
sha and the winner of that will get to
play Abel demro so it's either going to
be a run back for Noel to get that run
back against Abel de mro or sha will get
his first crack at him but either way
good match good match coming up next
here in the losers uh final which is
also going to be first of three so we're
going to have a little more games
semester around with
but considering the first two like uh
the first two games that they had where
Noel won two Z it felt kind of close but
Noel pretty was pretty confident in that
so you know he looked good absolutely
yeah and another thing we're going to
take a look at these good ass Tekken
shirts you guys are tuning again for
some good ass Tekken you guys could get
some good ass Tekken shirts now we have
the king one coming back in stock this
was the first one that ever came out
along with the martial law one as well
so if you guys want to catch these
shirts make sure to pre-order them now
because they do go out very quickly it's
o./ merch or scan that QR code I'll take
you to the link as well yeah but make
sure to follow benai Namco Esports on
their socials on Twitter and YouTube BN
Esports or you can follow Tekken as well
on the Twitter twitch or Facebook all on
Tekken uh make sure to check them out
and give them a
follow but we're here now in our top
three of the Teek online challenge here
South America uh I believe this is a
Bolivia mirror match in the in the
losers finals the winner will get to
play against Peru so pretty sweet you
know we got top threes fill that you
know normally we're pretty comfortable
with like seeing you know countries like
uh Peru in the top three right but bivia
I know has always had a very strong
Tekken Community but you know they
always and then when they go to these
major tournaments like Offline that
we've gone to it's always like one guy
one guy from Bolivia makes top eight
right so now it's get to see the entire
like scene like play in there and like
show up it's cool it's real real cool
yeah that's the beauty of these uh
events right Tekken online challenge
bringing it back with the Masters event
with several different regions around
the world so we could possibly see like
a lot of these players that we're not
too familiar with and just seeing some
good ass Tekken attached to that love to
see and Shia okay we didn't know this
WOW Shia is the one actually going to
the Eddie pick not a bell it's Shia
switching from Fang to a freaking Eddie
cuz he tried the Fang the first time you
know he got some he got pretty close but
he you know wasn't able to close it out
maybe he feels like he could do it with
Eddie here yeah you're the one that says
that out of the out of the characters
right you would expect AB Bel to pick
the Eddie against the the Steve but it
ends up being sha character we didn't
even know sha had so we have to see
whether or not his Eddie will be will be
any good here it's beeny weird though
cuz his his fang looks so so clean too
right yeah his fang was a blast to watch
like the way he just mixes up the
neutral game was so much
fun nice nice with punish there yeah
great wh punish the looking real clean
here not really scared of this oh mov
Gordo oh yeah you're and you're also an
like you also play Eddie so you you you
know his uh his faults yes I do Eddie's
still mad fun to play but man sometimes
it feels bad man oh I never play Eddie
so it feels great I I I'll never feel
bad oh dud the way that Noel gets all
these flicker twos man I love it yeah so
it's it's that has been the what since
what season 3 that that new uh counter
hit buff right I feel like every time
someone hits it on me it's like they
never expect it to
hit it's like still new to them you know
o nice wow Noel's with punishment is so
good yeah and his defense too he going
to break this wall no saves it MSI does
more Yep doesn't want that position or
anything like that o big whiff
nice dude you cannot whiff on Noel yeah
you know funny thing too is that that
was a great punish too cuz even if sha
had gone into relax after that that pick
up
oh oh he might get a resp okay okay that
angle was just right but then
the If he if he had got that that would
have been crazy oh my God he's still get
jab to get the float the Eddie is not
working out out yeah the Edd's
looking the righto gets the wall bounce
but no wall to bounce oh God down
to final chance for sh oh he didn't
stick the ballerina spit oh every time
man the ballerina spin it wall Splats
but only when the game feels like you
deserve it and that time the game was
like nah you didn't deserve it that time
nope that take that
away oh there I mean that was clean Noel
Noel showed showed that not it didn't
even feel like it was the any counter it
just felt like he was countering just
everything that that Shia even wanted to
attempt right like oh I'm going to try
this you know normal s at 3 plus4 Eddie
does that all the time right it's like
and Eddie's nor do do that all time but
Noah's like all right you can do that
but if you whiff it I'm going to punish
and he did every time so do every whiff
when Sonic fanged or blue Sonic fanged
and uh or even ford4 I yeah yeah even
the Ford for2 that one's a little bit
more confidence especially against a
character like Eddie because Eddie could
actually launch it with his wall
standing one three yeah that so it's
just like I know this is going to hit
that's just like the confidence there's
no way you're going to block it cuz this
is a whip punish and uh the way that
Noel is playing too I the the lot of
good things that I'm seeing from him is
that his spatial awareness man like he
the way that he's always fighting for
the wall even though he's not really
doing anything right just bunch of side
step walking side step blocking and
bunch of this stuff just for re
positioning for potential future damage
and stuff you know it's just yeah and
his low Parry rate and his whiff
punishment all top of the line yeah it's
it's really on point I mean you know
obviously since these guys are from the
same country you know I wonder how often
they they even play each other right so
maybe the the the Fang pick might not be
the sh's favorite pick against this but
I mean obviously he needs to go with
what got him this far here goes back to
the Fang here in the losers finals I
mean I guess I guess that was the point
right in the losers finals you do have a
first of three so you have at least an
extra cushion you know an extra game
extra game maybe try to run it out to
see if it would work there but
unfortunately didn't round now back to
the Fang the Fang was doing work too
Fang was yelling at his hand like why am
I in Final
Fantasy oh that was so sick that was
crazy what did he know did he see that
and then adjust it holy moly Noel uses
the peekaboo elbow launcher because
that's not going to be able to get
parried by thanks K my mind is blown my
mind is blown there might be there's
definitely some lasagna layers already
right yeah that was that was so much
layers for
sure nice every time he does back one he
punishes
it yeah I mean Noel seems so in his
element here with the Fang match up
too just looks so comfortable dude oh
what a hit got a little sticky there on
the pickup but it's okay out of range
for the side mix up final chance Noel
just so clean Noel is so clean yeah just
looking looking like he's just been
prepared for this this moment this
entire time right like everything that's
coming out he's wh punishing cleanly
setting things up stepping at the right
time being aggressive as patient at the
right time
oh Massi time
50/50 oh
Jesus his defense is crazy that's that's
the key right there his defense is
carrying him how did he lose this guy's
like almost a perfect player his whip
punishment's great like even his block
punishment like every time we block
fangs back one he punished it every time
like every time he like Shia wants to go
low he's blocking all of them or low
paying them I'm like what are you
supposed to do against a player like
this he's like your instinct right now
that make that makes that Eddie pick
seem a lot more reasonable now after we
just saw what happened because man that
just felt like Noel knew everything
right he knew exactly what what his
Tendencies were right oh I think you're
going to go low here oh you hit me with
this move but your normal setup here is
to go low afterwards right so I'm going
to block this low and point it's like
everything right that about that set
felt like it was all Noel was already
like I I I'm ready for this you know I'm
ready for even if it hits me I'm ready
for the follow-ups you know so didn't
even get flustered so it's like that he
just was in his Zone and in his element
so clean so clean yeah and like even you
know that's the that's the hard part too
with Shia we saw that the the the
neutral game was really effective
against Seri because you know it's the
character right where's he going to get
damage he's going to try to get the wy's
or the electrics for punishment but then
if you're always going into forward for
back turn and turning around with down
back you already already have high uh
high evasion while turning around so
it's really hard to squeeze an electric
in there but man it's just like every
time chia's whing there's a Sonic Fang
there and then every time he wants to
hit a button there's a b one every time
he wants to do a low it's getting low
parried or blocked it's feeling
impossible right now for sh yeah Noah's
playing at that range where it's like he
knows that b Kempo is not going to H hit
him right anything anything he does in B
kle won't hit him but if he does do
anything in B kle he can whiff punish
like he's in that range where it's like
I know as long as I'm back here you back
Tempo if you do anything I can wh punish
you you know so he just seems to be
prepared for every situation and it
doesn't even look like it like I can't
even like say like oh Shia's playing
this completely wrong like it just feels
like Shia's doing what he can but it's
just he's getting outplayed at every
turn by no oh yeah every every turn it
it's honestly crazy dude look at this
right back to where we left off punch
Perry setup no I went low like how does
he know how does he
know oh finally gets a counter down back
three catches them stepping couple of a
couple of reads working out for Shia
this round yeah Shia's definitely not
out of yeah he just needs to switch it
up and now you can see here you know see
a lot more patience less back turn
Kos right when I say that he does
it situations like that too right scary
nice though on the high good stuff yep
you got to be patient there got it on
the board here sh definitely not out of
this yet but got a long road ahead of
him no finally blocked that no got a
read there that defense again okay okay
sh bringing out the lows he's not
scared oh he's defin not scared of yeah
he's definitely not scared of finishing
that string either I like that
mhm nice gets the duck under the back
one squeezes the W standing four catch
oh miss messed up the 43 but it's okay
still alive but this is scary rage is
gone as long as he doesn't get counter
hit he's okay nice yeah the down back
three that's going to be a big move for
sha too because of the high Crush
capabilities and the counter hit two is
nice yeah and also the fact that Steve
can't launch it like other characters is
going to allow Fang players to be able
to use that a little more
freely didn't get the yeah didn't get
the pick up only a while standing for
punish under the duck high he could have
got a
launch all play get a little safe here
wants to get one game on the board here
oh he had it he could have got that's
pretty far that far it was really far I
yeah I don't think he should have ooh
but the wall bouts free wall b OO
ooh o
pleaseing in that shoulder for the high
wall spot I love the optimization wait
was that was that a triple shoulder wall
combo shoulder to hit him to the wall
high wall Splat shoulder and then down
one b no no he got the wall bouns he got
the wall bouns and down for three that
was so sick though that that was not
sick I'm all about that I mean that to
me that was Shia making the right
adjustments there back back to where
Noel what can Noel do you know like
that's what it felt like right it felt
that then that's the beauty of of sets
like this right where it's like you get
to see the adaptation that was a quick
adaptation too sh just made it look real
easy right he started doing a lot more
down back threes was a little bit more
patient but when he got his offense
going he kept it going which was crazy
good yeah and there was that one
instance too where he had the forward
four whiffed but then he did the back
turn down back and then he created extra
space made the Sonic Fang whiff for the
whiff punishment attempt and that's like
once you could get your opponent to stop
with punishing you for like moves like
that it's just like it makes them start
uh start second guessing their offense
or their wh punishment game and then
that's what we saw sha running away with
it got a couple of the big homing moves
into the guaranteed followup and then
also too like since Shia's neutral he's
using so much of the the empty back
Tempo and not always doing an attack out
of it this time he he just held the back
Temple for like the fullest length and
then did the low out of it and yeah like
that's what allows him to open up that
kle game even more just doing the fake
ones but he you know he loves forward
forward you know like that that that
move right there we uh is known as in
Japan uh Ed move right God the gods for
form yep gods for for yep yeah so sha
you know his play style is very similar
to Ed and I like that right it's like a
very very you know attack heavy but at
the same time very patient oh look at
this dude The Stairway to Heaven right
there that was actually Godlike I I need
I man I need we need to go go back Japan
I need to walk up some stairs like that
again fight they just need to go back to
Japan all right
wow okay both of these guys Noel with
the walls facing but Shia finds the back
one of his own yeah challenging but what
a whip punish there from wh punishment
is so on
point it's actually
ridiculous yeah shout whipping a lot out
in the open but it's not that big of a
deal oh but one Jack back one he back
one a down back three you know that
that's actually possible he back one
Fang's down back three on the first yeah
on the first couple frames there's the
high Crush isn't instant instant yeah I
think that's the case with most high
Crush moves like they don't they don't
instantly have high Crush frames unless
it's out of Crouch or something like
that yeah he totally back one a down
back three there he deserves it you love
to see it love that I hate
that man but Noel's defense now is like
really carrying his offense here oh oh
doubles up Guess The Stomp to back turn
mix that move plus frames that move for
sha has been so good but he hasn't
abused it too much little worried about
it he's just trying to find anything
that was the opportunity he created it
with the forward
four yeah a lot of Whi for four3 is now
coming out for sha lot of wh Noel just
back dashing away not giving the sweet
clean hit range and then there's no mix
there yep Noel now one round away from V
the grand finals to face Abel the
Maestro sh going to have to make a huge
comeback here but it's definitely
possible oh stand one though could have
got a opportunity yeah just a w standing
one check he could have got the three
that's all right though he still has the
slight lead
here he's it's about tied now now he
lead drastic go down what the hell Happ
drastic go down 66% chance oh
everything's going to get punished oh my
God all right know he ain't out of it
though he's got rage oh The God Who side
okay good good safe combo Jesus round
forward four man that one pesky Fang
move he us he uses it like a whiff
electric mhm you really got to whip bag
forward four is so good it
is nice and this time those cample
transitions aren't going to work out and
don't whiff man I got these yeah I mean
it's not that big of a punish right say
it's hard for Steve to to whip punish
these things cleanly but any whip punish
is better than nothing yeah look at that
he's already got got himself back in the
lead Sonic Fang as a wh Punisher is
great but the damage is kind of
whatever yeah sh slight life deficit
here but to make no didn't get the
forward input for the screw that's not
good oh but then the first couple onews
wh so he only got the last hit parried
OH Close now sh oh my
God nice
block Rage that's he's going to have to
make this come back real Quick's got to
go in and he recognized it intercepted
with the up forward what no l with such
a clean Steve making his way back to the
Grand finals for sha you know I got to
give it up for sha man he played his
hardart out he played his hard out there
I mean he made that Fang look good man
it and that that's a tough match
obviously because it looked honestly
Noel looked so good in that set right
the first two games spe specifically
looked unbeatable you know like how did
he lose that's what we said we said how
did he even lose to get here to this
point you know so for for sha to be like
no no no it's not that close he doesn't
beat me that that bad the all the time
right let me show you guys how it
normally goes like and then just it's
like all right all right the game was
close but Shia just couldn't you know
clutch it out at the end there uh but
nice showing from Noel though man Noel
doing work there and getting to the to
the Grand finals against Abel yeah
congratulations to all the competitors
that entered here today at the Tekken
online challenge South America event but
man those were some good matches dude
that was great play great play but now
we're going to be jumping back into the
grand finals between Abel and Noel
before we do that you get you guys can
check out all the master events that are
going to be coming up and the regional
final events you can see the uh the
schedule here we are in the region 3
South America there's going to be region
four tomorrow with West Europe and so on
and so forth pretty much every weekend
throughout the month of uh September and
even like the first couple weeks of
October so make sure to to be on the
lookout for all these events as well as
the regional finals they will be
streamed here so make sure to be look be
looking out for them and entering
themselves if you have an opportunity to
so right yeah so that just means good
ass Tekken on these weekends for the
remainder of the year and yeah I'm
excited man I just love seeing good
Tekken dude this is awesome and it's
like I more more so for us specifically
I like seeing Tekken from from the
communities that don't get that much
shine you know because right yeah
because I'll be let me be completely
honest right maybe before Tekken 7 right
maybe even before I would say before tag
two even because tag two we started
really kind of finding out more about
like uh you know all these other little
regions but more so teken 6 it always
felt like it was Korea Japan and then
you had Europe and and America and that
was kind of yeah that's we because we
genuinely didn't know that there was
scenes out there in South America but
but people and and in Pakistan right but
you'd always have people that would come
from those areas and be like yo our our
scene out there is so strong you know
like there'd be dudes from Pakistan that
would that that would like actually like
yo our scene out there is crazy strong
and we're just like well we haven't seen
it so we don't know you know we don't we
honestly been the tale yeah we we've
heard about like little rumors here and
there like K when he was out here he
would tell us about it too and it's just
like little things here and there it's
just like but it's just like we just
haven't got the exposure for it so we
never got to really see it like that but
now it's yeah now in this day and age
where you know online tournaments are
still a thing streaming is a thing now
and it's just like you know the fact
that tekken's gotten so big worldwide
and that now even though like we can
actually take these big tournaments to
the regions you know when we were able
to pre pandemic right and then just have
these all the players show up and just
like yo we are hella good at this game
you know we love this game and we're not
even from any are that you guys even
thought about before right I was like
going going to Peru in 2019 for
Collision right I was just like it was
like a time capsule because it's like
dude they played tag one here
religiously and it's like Tekken 7's
like the side game for them it's like
dude just because a game's older doesn't
mean that it has to die out or like
nobody can play it they keep that game
alive out there and you see the Le play
transfer over here but then also too
like the fundamentals still carry over
throughout all the teken games and it's
just like if you're good in tag one
you're going to be good in second 7even
too it's just ah you just have to you
just have to update yourself a little
bit with like the new moves the system
stuff but
man man this is the funny thing too is
like we're gonna we're g to watch a
player right here and Abel demro right
who's an Eliza Eddie man but I've seen
him play tag two or tag one tag one and
he's like good at that game too I'm like
w how's this guy so good at all these
games how you going be good at a game
from 20 20 20 years ago at a game that
was like right now you know right but
here we go Grand finals Noel versus Abel
at the wow the doors are
open how need what what hey how come
geese does his intro the doors don't
stay open then huh they all Clos behind
what the I've never seen that that is
blowing my mind
a this stage is so cool too man dude the
bottom stage is so pretty just like the
whole outside of the the inside's
already gorgeous right but man look
outside with the blossom like everywhere
like dude this is amazing all right so
we're going to skip the match that we
saw in the winners finals it's going to
be Eliza versus Steve Fox here and we
saw we saw you know Abel do work with
Eliza original Tekken uh five Steve
outfit let's go oo side step rocket
launcher is
good I mean that's one of no one of
Noel's biggest strengths I think is his
movement right his ability to like there
micro side steps like that like that and
he's blocking on a dime side step block
side step uh throw break right there
like his defense is so good and his
movement is so crisp and it's
interesting too with Steve right cuz
Steve's not necessarily a character that
can s step and get a huge punish off of
it right he's more poke poke poke but
that's where Noel's
comfortable yeah he's definitely
utilizing all all the movement options
and so good with the whip punishment too
oh man but yeah not the side too though
his mixup with those Fireballs just kind
of using oh but you can't stay ducking
in his face forever dude he duck for a
split second and bended while nice block
too no l no l is something else man I'm
seeing something something new
here yeah he's looking good I mean his
defense is looking good but his offense
as well mixing it up
perfectly so nice with it rocket
launchers just a bunch of mid checks
right now B not biting though it's the
left weave 311 yep that's one of his
strengths man his ability to step and
weave too utilizes both of them yeah he
doesn't always just go for one yeah
especially in this match up too so good
for getting around El Li small game like
her uh down three or down for one little
game like that from Eliza superly easy
dealt with with the we but man right
there unfortunate for a bell has one
more chance gets the wild standing two
into the ex dive kick pickup easy combo
conversion smart choice now Bell's
really utilizing that Crouch mixup right
gets in the face either goes with the
wall standing or the down three yeah
right there saw him burn the whole super
meter instantly at the end of the round
and look at that he's already almost
back at one
stock only 10 seconds into the next
round but man he gets the counter it
back one he was expecting that to break
the wall but the angle made it not
happen
yeah Noel's us utilizing that back one
like crazy now cuz recognizing that
Abel's not really you know doing much
more than just crouching right so he's
got to try to utilize that back one to
interrupt but man no Abel's dropping
these combos big
drop okay still winning the and gets the
tackle into the punches last one got
blocked rage drives in play this is
terrifying Steve with rage is so scary
he got a gun with one
bullet it was a
blank nice oh my God wasn't the right
punish already Jesus God oh my
God Ste fox is like just resist
death nice nice step dude his movement
so good yeah but it's Abel's Abel's
aggressiveness he doesn't care right he
gets in his
face it's not just 2D characters
everybody can jump wow man Noel making
this come back here 2 one it's good
final round first
game well coming from losers though oh
no break on the one plus
two good start there for
aell Keeps the pressure up in and out
play didn't get the pick up got duck
one does it finish the stream oh goes
for the damn that went under down down
forward
one yeah is super low
profile oh he had it but he went for the
high finisher little less risky get the
running two at the wall break no l up
one game dang very very close set there
I mean honestly that was just it was
Tail of Two tapes right it it was the
defense from Noel and being able to to
like deal with uh Abel's full Crouch
mixup right cuz a lot of times Abel he
gets into the dive kick and then as soon
as he's that range it's either going to
be the wall standing attacks or down
three right so a lot of the Mix-Ups
there but Noel just waited for for him
to duck and as soon as he ducked he's
like all right I'm going to tie my back
one to make sure that it just counter
hits you because he's gotten that a few
times that was so tight he calls out
like right when he's doing the wild sing
attack wait not not yet not yet that's
the bait if I do it instantly they're
going to duck and yeah and then just
wait a half second and then back one
while they're doing their while sing
attack and that's what he's counter
hitting and and everything else too
about Noel like the the micro side step
into block micro side step into throwra
Michel side step into getting whatever
wh punish he can either it be 112 either
it be Sonic Fang you know it's just like
Steve is such a safe character that when
he gets a sip 112 or a sip Sonic fan any
lead feels like he's building a wall if
Steve has the lead and I have to
approach Steve now I have to get around
his back one and down forward to to get
in on
it I mean but that's the reason why this
match up has been so good here because
Abel has been finding ways around it as
well both these guys have been adapting
pretty well to each other so very very
interesting set here Violet systems for
game number two Abel CH uh choosing the
stage here see if this will go well for
him Viet systems and geometric plane
definitely uh two of my favorite
tournament stages in my opinion just no
funny business in the corners you know
some of the Tekken stages have like
hexagon stage out uh uh layouts and
stuff or sometimes the corners right
there they're not true 90° Corners
except for the last two stages I just
mentioned
yeah like you guys seen it when a side
wall turns into a forward wall or a
forward wall turn into a side wall maybe
yeah these Corner the corner walls are
tricky they they like to play tricks on
You O got the counter hit though going
to get the wall hit this this time
triple quadr Tri dive kick combo did the
jump over into a little weird mixup oh
and he's still getting it oh my goding
two mileage
dude and now Noel's going to have to
make this comeback now without rage too
it's going to be honest comeback and he
can't do it had to force the 5050 just
bet it all right there after the running
two used up the resources of the rage
Drive anyway so it's just like why not
if it hits I'm back in it yeah Bell
going for the low Parry too knowing that
if any low Parry you know any low that
he parries will automatically get him
the win so opting not to risk the block
there oh he knew it wasn't in time so he
didn't cancel into DP such great
presence of
mine oh blue spark mix up nice side sh
and he's going to use the super look at
all this damage this is from a
jab oh wall was it was from a jab in 2
met it was it she got the wall combo too
yeah then then I I would expain a little
bit more harder
oh got running slide that's a minus 10
get up three that's a delay get up three
oh R Drive expended could breathe a
little easier here but Steve's still
coming oh they traed oh my
God
round fight what just
happened oh my God it traed oh what the
oh my
God oh
no what a whiff punish Abel still
awake extending the carry as much as
possible you almost got wall to wall you
almost got wall to wall woo the right
weave dude this weave usage is
phenomenal oh the double double pump one
plus two break
nice they're speeding up right now
revving up right now this is where AB
Bel lost last time oh the down jab
though not going for a launch oh no this
is trouble this is trouble Noel with the
ultra Instinct low par 5050 god dude
Abel just willing to go for the down jab
at that timing the trade there I know
too could have been could have been ugly
but he paid off there b now with the
lead here things are getting spicy Eliza
full meter again any jab punish is going
to be a full
combo that mean you do know Abel does
have those low dive kicks into the jab
combos too so M this meter is going to
lead to a lot of damage those are so
nasty oh
God playing so patient right not forcing
himself into getting mixed up like that
I got back one counter hit that might be
round trap while sending one into back
one he'll trade with Jabs
boom
round fight all right here we go Noel
needs to reset it he's already up one
game tied it up in the round count here
gets the pickup after the moonl four
this is huge is he going to go for Oki
no he does but the 311 dude Noel is a
god at the weaves man I'm telling you
man it's the weave game especially
against Eliza is crazy oh but good look
at that dude never hit with his back to
the wall but Abel picks it up and he's
going for the hard stuff and he gets it
nice Abel with the execution fire ass oh
you're in the corner now that's bad news
oh get off me exire get off I
can't oh the hit him just a
b you know if he had blocked the low he
might have been able to block the mid
too like almost like block thought he
was going to yeah I thought he was going
to I think he was thinking that he was
going to block the low first and then
the mid but the low width and then only
the mid got there so oh that is good
this is some good ass second right here
damn Noel looking to reset it 20 already
20 yeah I mean Noel's looking real real
good here I mean those weaves and those
steps everything that just those small
movements right but he's capitalizing on
them so much now you know before I said
like oh you know he's going just Sonic
Fang or just pokes right he's not really
going for the big hits but now he
recognizes I can go for the big hits 311
especially if they're walls to the back
right there or to the side where he can
get a wall Splat oo it is Big damage
there so he's capitalizing on this and
the other thing too is that whatever his
back to the wall it's not his his back's
never to the wall it's like he's there
for one second and ab Bel thinks oh I
have the pressure I got to mix him up
now and one one weave or just one step
he's already out of there you know and
that's the thing too right like if you
weave at a bad timing Steve can't block
it all yeah but if you weave at a good
timing and he's doing it at the right
time it's not like he's just mashing
weaves and like guessing to get away
from stuff like he can't block during
that whole weave transition so the fact
that and then the time he's using it is
like when his backs against the wall
Eliza wants to go for the 50/50 uh you
know it's very common to side up left uh
Akuma and Eliza's down three to the left
but Steve if Force Crouch or not it
doesn't matter because left weave is
always going to come out left weave so
as long as he has the timing on when he
wants to go for that down three or or
the down jab or the down forward one
he's eliminating a lot of the options
from Eliza's small game there yeah but
returning to the Violet systems here
Abel going to rock the Eliza still so
going to run the set you know one thing
that I remember him using a lot in the
Winner's final set that he's not using
too much in this one is the homing
attack right forward three I believe it
is oh down forward three yeah the wall
down three yeah I mean that homing
attack is crazy cuz not only does it
Crush lows but it like you go it's
basically 360 hit range right cuz it's a
hom attack
mhm safe mid wall bounce ooh yeah a lot
of a lot of help there but Abel hasn't
really had any opportunities to use that
and every time he has no well gets out
before he even gets the opportunity to
think about it right but here is is the
ball pressure game this is the the the
part of the game that's been big here
wow oh my
God it almost feels like Noel's using
the wall to his Advantage even though
it's like it's supposed to be a Bell's
pressure right it feels like Noel's
using it and like a I'm going to win my
back's to the wall
wall was playing out of his mind gets
the pick up wall kind of a weird spot
gets it perfectly goes for
damage did the saf for uh
Fireball wow went for the whole thing
you know that's there is a little mix
there if you try to punish the second or
the third hit uh that's why he finished
the whole thing if you if you try to
punish it the the fourth hit could get
you yeah and there wasn't much time left
either so it wasn't a terrible move from
no well but a pretty predictable one
but you you have to go for it with only
like 5 4 seconds left on the clock right
absolutely
yeah oh here comes the weave again just
a shoulder tap just to get him out of uh
the wall safely and theall using a lot
more guard brakes here
now oh that py dark wave one just stays
has the shield right in front of her oh
I love that moong Glide and he delays it
super
late one one pressure at the wall not
overc committing for the low he's like
you know I've been weaved way way too
much in this set already I'm just going
to keep it even
smaller yeah just playing it very close
very compact not taking too many risk
especially the midrange yeah time
becoming a factor this this is where it
gets tough for Steve you know when you
have like a 50 60% likely and he's
forced to make a comeback you're not
giving him any counter hits you're and
and then at that point you're just kind
of looking for the foot stop or the mid
mix up there yeah and and the foot stops
easy to deal with cuz you just keep them
out of range yeah and the open you just
back dash it man well just tried to do
311 there but Abel did one one and it
tracked
him spinning that ball nice challeng wow
dude like he's so good at hitting that
too on counter hit oh he went for the
grounded hit on the Blue Duck too but
then the side roll save the but then the
blue Sonic Fang it's going to be enough
yes Noel Staying Alive in this game
here Noel looking for the reset point if
he wins this game it's a reset yeah you
would much rather reset it here don't
let don't let Abel get one game
inell so clean with the ex dive kick
pickup after the wall sanding to nice
gets the wall combo this
time the extra long delay the left weave
again down jab into W stand2 but the big
combo drop didn't get dive kick this
time this is huge this is huge jab to
fight his way out of the corner oh oh so
scary second
oh God oh God he was looking for the
whip punish on the wild standing for
didn't get there in time the
shield oh
oh the weaves man the weaves the weav
are so good
point Noel's weave timing
is incredible dude it is crazy
right oh nice called them out on it
spends the met another
meter just for a little extra got the
counter hit this is all natural no he
did the third hit and he got under his
legs doesn't matter though aell still
alive gets one on the board two to one
now yeah I mean he's going to be alive
regardless of whether or not Noel wins
cuz Noel is in the loser side so he has
to reset Abel demro Abel one game closer
to not getting reset to just winning
this straight out but it's going to be a
tough one for both players honestly cuz
it feels tough for for aild Dev cuz he
has to win two games in order to win
this set it also feels tough for no cuz
he has to win one game just to reset the
set to make it z z yeah they both they
both F like they both sound like they're
fighting the hardest fight of their life
dude when you put it that way that
sounds
terrible neither of them neither of them
feel like they're they're in position to
win you know that's the messed up part
either way they're going to be stressed
out but yeah I think everybody is feing
for the reset we just want to see more
Tekken man we're right there with you
but you know one person that doesn't
want to see the definely a bell it's
just like I'm trying to go I'm trying to
end it man I'm trying to have a good
rest of my day screw this man I don't
want to deal with weave or back ones
anymore I'm tired of
it to turn on practice mode just have
Steve just do three the entire time like
I'm going to just hit you while do three
not like not even like paying attention
just like I just I just need this just
to feel good this is Justice he just
need to beat you up real quick this is
Revenge all right here we go game number
four now between these two great
players man and taking it to the
Forgotten
World forgotten round again yeah like
this seems to be the stage choice I I
definitely don't mind it especially with
Eliza too because her floor break comos
are kind of booty now without the dive
kick three yeah it's very
true and you know honestly for Noel too
I like this choice because he does still
keep the walls which I think has been
benefiting him a lot more than it's been
benefiting uh Bell Dude the micro
movement from Noel is so sick either it
be a weave or a micro side step into
block he just does such a good job at
working around that look at that side
step into back one two takes the plus
frames didn't get the pickup
though yeah I mean every time he blocks
a dive kick right he's already kind of
stepping he's already kind of looking
for the for abil to continue his
pressure and then he counters and hit
with the counter at back one oh that's
me damn round
two
fight this is scary for aell man he's
just trying to find an opening but every
time he does anything kind of slow back
one's always a threat or the overc
commitment and then the weaves come out
and it just makes it evade everything
yeah butell still getting his offense
going here forcing mixups man hard
mixups and no well is like enough of
this no more slides no more
nothing oh
oh oh o look at this dashing from both
left weave again oh my goodness Noel on
reset Point way out of his mind oh man
those weaves have been so good so good
but look at this combo from Abel going
to break the floor going to get a little
damage
here okay guess the peekaboo 10 count
what's the option here just run up
peekaboo
offense
oh from both players now no not
overextending just kind of waiting to
see Abel do something
yep oh went for it okay gu so good at
that he's been getting the pickup every
time going to get the wall Too Little
Too Close yeah a little too close for
that car doesn't matter and he still
gets to save the fireball meter because
the down three kill
yep oh again though the P one counter
Hits and The Well has been getting one
every set is this Christmas no's making
this Christmas for me I love
this woo didn't get the wall
though that was counter
two man you see these these a lot of
down Jabs coming out from a bell
just trying to stay under Steve's
eyes dive kick pressure at the wall but
the micro side step from Noel so good
jumps over final chance
W and that's an instance where the weed
got him caught for it he couldn't block
there and Abel did the smart move right
did a homing attack as well kind of
figuring that was going to be a step or
or a weave
damn close game here possible The Shield
The Shield the is so messed
up wow caught him ducking in case the
flicker one down one happen nice got got
the again dude he's just always staying
out of range oh my
God this could be it this could be it
for a and we got the reset no l just
playing so textbook man honestly just so
textbook like the the movement the
fundamentals when you have to go for the
Low parries Low Blocks and sometimes you
you can't just react to everything
sometimes you got to take the read on
the lows like the moong the moong Glide
4 he did earlier like yep man he's
playing good he's playing really good so
many thinks that he's doing well
honestly Abel's not playing terrible
either but I think Abel is starting to
fall into almost like a uh sort of like
a once something once his offense flow
starts going he kind of sticks with it
and I think Noel is that's where he's
capitalized he's like I can step here I
can I can make a step if he even knows
he can't step he's patient he's like all
right I don't want to step here I'll
just keep blocking so that's when and
that's when you kind of get this false
sense of security right so that's when
like Abel's like he's just blocking he's
not stepping okay I can mix him up as
soon as he tries to mix up that's when
the side step comes in it's like
everything about it is is just so so
smart yeah it's so good it's so good and
like most of the time too like AEL is uh
doing a lot of down Jabs a lot of full
crouch in his face to try to like
predict the back one and then W standing
two and he's been getting a couple W
standing twos on normal hit and counter
hit and stuff but it's so risky man
those W standing to's Miss timeing
you're getting back one all right so
we're going to reset the game here reset
the entire set it's z z winners Grand
finals both of these guys are in the
losers bracket so the next person to win
this set wins the entire tournament
obviously and this is infinite Azure 2
so we're going to go to straight to an
infinite stage for the first game here
both these guys seem to like wal stages
but the infinite stage here
going be going to be interesting to see
how this plays out for both players so
pretty so pretty damn you see her
looking at the stars too pretty the Moon
is too bright I'm a
vampire wait aren't they okay with the
moon yeah they're supposed to be but
she's like but that makes no sense if
they don't like the Sun but the moon's
reflecting the Sun's light I don't get
it
either all right just making sure make
sure my vampire L is
correct all right but about you know oh
oh DK oh okay D he was willing to pull
that out for why why not yeah hell yeah
right I'm about
it especially after playing so solid off
of a there it is down jab while standing
two another pattern that we've seen from
a bell before yeah a lot of it actually
and it's been working out for
him yeah he's just going for any type of
high Crush because Steve is just a just
pestering with these back ones and one
two ones and flicker Jabs all high but
man that's why scary that's why that
down jab is is being like such a strong
tool for again the W setting to this
time is counter hit uses the meter to
extend the combo to get a little more
damage back to zoning back to building
meter back to building a wall oh good
Lowry nice call out on that down
jab dude like he he blow pares like the
down Jabs almost all the time too it's
crazy I mean both of these guys
definitely seem to be getting more
comfortable with each other's play
Styles which is the the fun part about
it right cuz not whenever you play
someone the same setups aren't going to
always work oh nice y I agree I agree
you know if you're a bell here right you
you might want to take some stock into
the fact that you're winning on an
infinite stage too that's a very good
point yeah that's a very good
point but then both these characters are
kind of funny in that way where their
lows become stronger at the wall because
there's nowhere else to move and I think
yeah that's what AEL wants to use to for
his character but yeah he's playing
great on this infinite stage right now
honestly the the one spot where he
thinks he's the at the most Advantage
right he yeah it's always been getting
game screwed yeah the weave 311's been
getting him
killed so that's what I'm saying like in
a stage like this where it's all out in
the open he might be better right chance
nice big chance Pi up
too can not going to spend the rage he
hit the first dive kick at was a little
far so instead of going for the Triple
dive kick he off go fors gets a move to
and the foot stop is good he side rolled
too early early a bell first game of the
reset still awake very very very good
yeah clean 302 you know honestly that
step that stomp right there was not
guaranteed he tried to roll which is the
right option but you got to roll at the
right timeing he did too early which
makes it easy easy to step on but if you
roll right when they get right over your
body you can avoid it not the best
situation still but you avoid dying so
that's
in that do or die scenario yeah you just
have to time it and he did the right
option just a little too early a little
too early there but uh I think I think
the pattern we've been seeing coming out
of Noel is that every time he loses
we're going to go to forgotten realm mhm
I think he likes the wall stage I mean
obviously he's he's he's benefited from
the wall whether it be to Bell's back or
to his back because when it's his back
he's getting he's side stepping out of
there and getting a wall Splat where
it's the bell's back to the wall that's
where he can get all of his mix-up
started so uh I think I think it's
pretty I think it's going to be a pretty
safe bet unless he wants to go to
another wall stage maybe but I don't
know I think this one's fine I I think
forgotten real is fine unless he like
wants to swap characters or something
that'd be sick maybe he has a
Lars don't smile like that don't smile
like that I was kidding I was
kidding D you're really trying to make
this Christmas for me
huh
I forgotten realm yet again Noel
choosing it I mean it's a good stage I
think for for for
him brought a great Point yeah the the
the fact that the Bell just won so
cleanly on the infinite stage uh if he
loses this one the stage uh the stage
select does go to him so he can go back
to the infinite stage we'll see if
that's going to be his style too you
know he's a he seems to have his own
sort of a game plan so oh got the swipe
S no swipy it wasn't even ex yeah who
I've never seen anyone use a swipe like
that just straight up for the counter
here properties ooh the down jab there
but the Step again look at that even the
mid check afterwards no bueno left weave
oh oh big chance oh it could have been
way more yeah B hasn't launched that
once yet okay this is it this is it you
can break the floor sidewall rard is
good no that jinxed it never mind
that rard hit box is so J
times oh man you used to always get mad
at Suk why don't you R he's like it
misses all the time yeah he yeah he he
is right on that one yeah I'm not going
to blame him for that cuz honestly we
all thought that was going to hit you
said it's good I saw I I've seen yeah I
don't know why I said it's good because
I've seen straight wall Splash clean as
day wall Splat and then Eliza goes for a
RAR and it whips I have seen those I
would have I said it good because it
seemed good to
me that was
unfortunate oh man ex Fireball though is
good but the Bell not not shooking he's
an Eliza player so he knows that was
going to whip yeah if you're an Eliza
player you have to know that's going to
whip yeah yeah he's he's already seen it
not the first day on the job for him
yeah definitely not ties it up here to
1-1 so now
oh this time checking with the down
three after the flicker one down one
since it is zero C players are
definitely taking notes on what your uh
responses on block after
that yeah I think there's a lot of note
taking here between both of these
players right who he thought he had the
wh punish he was just out of range
though B's playing a definitely more and
more patient now right not not trying to
fight so hard for the wall positioning
either just kind of fighting in the
middle like let's fight here and a lot
more throws too but the low Parry Noel
that's so good with it oh messed up the
flicker he got the albatross oh that
almost wored that almost worked who are
that almost worked if Eliza wasn't so
small that might have
worked okay gets the lead with that
okazi he still has to burn time rage
Drive is gone exd and it was going to
burn the two seconds anyways
genius genius can you can you can you
interrupt it after the first first block
can you you think can you punch her
between the first and the second one I'm
not sure yeah that cuz that's that's
risky but it might be possible to
interrupt but that was so smart from
Abel anyways waste the time and get the
hit too dude Abel this time he went for
dive kick into snake Edge the snake is
actually a homing attack to catch the
weave but the weave still got
there oh he got the floor break too
that's it right okay may you know what
we don't stingy he got stingy on the
meter but doesn't matter he still got
one more turn with it anyways aell
looking good now gaining hell momentum
here yeah two Z Now real clean I mean it
looked like it I wouldn't say it looked
like a struggle in that first set right
but it was definitely leaning towards
Noel's uh uh momentum but Abel takes it
takes it back real fast and I mean
that's a that's a sign of a great player
right he recogniz obviously you know
we're we're commentators we can
recognize it too but as in the in the
the of the battle yeah it's hard
sometimes it's hard to recognize these
things especially when you're constantly
thinking about what do I need to do I'm
not punishing this correctly I'm not
punishing that but for him he's like oh
yeah I started to recognize the things
that I'm getting I'm getting hit by let
me try to neutralize those things a
little bit while also capitalizing on
any momentum I can get and he's doing a
great job with it yeah the the wild
standing twos are still doing work for
him and like yeah uh and also too like
the The Weave he he's definitely trying
out different answers for the left weave
because we saw dive kick into snake
which is a homing attack which could
catch him there but then the fact that
the Wii 311 came out so fast it just
beat her to the punch but yeah Abel
doing great work and he's he's getting a
little bit uh crazier with the moon
Glide mixes too like he's going yeah
he's been doing the low a lot more uh
liberally now he's just like you know
what screw it you blocked one you ain't
GNA block them all and I I love the way
he uses it too he pushes all the way
through just to try to see like are you
trying to whiff punish me no okay I'm
mixing up it's just like oh I want to
show you the moon Glide it's kind of
like how law players show you the slide
input and then do the slide it's kind of
like the same idea there sometimes the
slowest ones are usually the fastest
yeah sometimes you got sometimes you got
to show them the slow ones man you got
to show them the slow ones you gotta let
them know like hey these these you think
that's all Fast N these are slow too and
but now it's a change up too it's a
change up it messes with you look at all
the details on the top part of the stage
man look at that star thing back there
know you never never even knew that was
there yeah you never see that I've never
seen that before until we see that was
sick I want that in my
room it looks like Nova's
symbol damn again with the low par no
well oh
god oh big back one counter hit though
still getting it damn it's Christmas and
and my birthday this is amazing
and the one thing too is Abel you know
like some of his offense hasn't
necessarily been working out but he
still goes to it he's not scared like
he's not he doesn't shy away from it he
still utilizes it because he knows it's
still a part of his options but right
there Noel taking that first round
cleanly
fight and even right there still not uh
shying away from the moonl four and was
a Do or Die scenario
[Music]
anyways get off of me or H back one get
out the air
go the flip over expdp no okazi I don't
want to hold
nothing nice good
St wow great step he could have have the
swipe and now the pushing AB Bells back
to the wall one 2 one the counter
here no trying to fight back here he's
going to have to do it it's the long
climb
right it's a long climb but he's already
halfway there oh
[Music]
yeah oh just fishing for these rocket
launchers at the wall three of
them all right no never mind Maybe not
maybe maybe he's not halfway there b
fighting back yeah a lot of down Jabs
lot of down threes to stay under uh back
one overextended with the 442 got the
block and the wall break this is huge
rard is coming into play nice and safe
oh my God it's going I had to hold my
breath on that one it's going to hit
it's going to
hit and the kill to Abel Staying Alive
here if he just wins this game he is the
champion but if not Noel will will uh
bring the set up to two to one right
Noel's been putting up such a great
fight getting the bracket reset and
everything I mean yeah he's been so
impressive with this movement with his
with his conversions and everything but
Abel's defense and offense too have been
both out of this he had it he had it
didn't get the special cancel though got
the mid this time great check oh the
left weave
again got the low goes for the ex dive
kick going to huge it could kill he
could even burn one more to make sure it
could kill but no he's going to save it
he's confident he can get it there we go
tournament point a
bell tournament point
here Tekken online challenge for South
America a champ can be crowned here with
if Abel wins this round oh nice side
with punish there Noel doesn't want it
to happen yet though his movement is so
crisp that oh doesn't no well just kind
of not there like we seen oh but he got
that back one though yeah and that's the
nerves kicking oh but he still get
though low wall it's not going to hit
oh this is bad news for Bell he's going
to have to fight
out that actually worked out that
actually worked
out that worked out so good for Noel
actually getting hit by the second
Fireball saved him from getting wall
splattered by the moong Glide to there
wow you know that's the second time he's
gotten hit by the second hit of the ex
Fireball both both times it seemed to
help him out in the situ it put him in a
situation where he took some damage but
he got out of the the worst situation
that was coming up after toward so I
mean if that's a that if that's a if
that's a strat it's not bad if if it's
got him out of some losses here though
that is a very interesting but good
Strat you know it's just like I'm
honestly I'm honestly wondering if he
got if he if he's getting hit on purpose
yeah because ball yeah cuz you don't
have to take the Mi mix anymore yeah and
the first and the first and the first
time he did it too he was grounded so he
took the he blocked it and then he just
took the second one and then the moong
Glide just went right through and that
was
it yeah it's not the first time for sure
I don't know if he's pressing a button
or if he it honestly looks like he's
getting hit by it intentionally just I
think I think he is getting hit by
intention I think that that he just
doesn't want to deal with the mix
afterwards which is honestly just
extremely smart that's so smart that's
the he's the first guy I've even seen uh
you know Implement that strategy and
that's such a smart strategy when you
think about sure you take a little bit
of damage on the second Fireball but
what's a second Fireball compared to a
wall bouncing freaking ex Moon Glide 2
yeah dang that SS good all right
abandoned Temple here so Abel not going
for the infinite but going for one of
the bigger wall stages so he's going to
have a lot more room to mess around here
which I I do enjoy this is my favorite
one of my favorite big wal stages
because it's just enormous has cool ass
music you see Akuma you know he kicks it
here walks his dog here ah that was the
key word
Akuma no the the moon's red too I like I
like red moons I guess I don't know I
like the stage just because it's big
actually yeah it is definitely a lot of
play players a favorite biggest wall
stage with no breakable walls no funny
business yeah it gives you a lot of room
to operate but yeah at the same time
when you get when you get to the wall
you get you get to still apply your
pressure but then also the the one
reason I don't like this stage
personally there's no 90° corners for
these walls so sometimes those side
walls could turn to straight walls but
most of the time it doesn't happen in
the
stage all right here we go though Abel
still on tournament point two to one
Noel looking to tie it up look look at
that offense all from a side step back
one two then he got the mid followup and
he practically got the round just off of
that yeah oh big whiff though big wh big
Whi big
Whi both players were trying to Whi
punish each other and both of them were
out of range until Noel at the
last his first Whi brought him
closer that's so funny
actually ooh the one throw again
actually it's a one or two now
I mean B's he's throwing too like he's
actually doing these throws on purpose
so yeah
definitely you know it is still
something that could add to the mental
stack you know right for
sure all right the jump away he's just
Scouting For the ex dive kick he's just
like I have the lead I don't have to do
anything oh
no that's huge that's
huge jab interrupt get out of here he
said this is so scary for both players
oh second hit with but he went for a
high punish ex ex kick out of the air
he's going to be able to
oh I wonder if he get a combo after that
after that ex uh DP cuz didn't do the
animation right yeah that is one of the
newer changes to uh Eliza If you catch
someone Airborne out of expdp they have
to get hit by the second part but yeah
it saves her but I'm not sure she could
have got another conversion there it was
so high up yeah it seems it seems very
hard though this time we saw dive kick
into standing four which is a homing
attack and that is going to beat our
left weave the little adjustments oh the
big homing attack you ain't stepping
nowhere Bell now one
round it feels like this every time it
feels like someone has the advantage but
they're the ones leading it's so hard
man so hard oh power crush is
good oh the the the fireball from Crouch
[Music]
interesting threatening andell's
spanning this meter just hitting those
buttons trying to
just get the lead here and he's got it
he's got a huge lead tackle
punches oh no that could be final round
here possible tournament Point here for
Abel
demro very close damn that is active for
days holy moly yeah you saw in the wall
just kind of waiting it out wanted to
punish but he knew he couldn't that is
oh this is scary mid or low mid or low
he treding to the standing four is there
for the left weave but the one time he
does it the one time he doesn't do the
standing four he did down forward four
and then then he left weave but he got
the down jab DP super this is going to
be close sidewall the sidewalls going
mess it
up R he's got the rage though
sh this is
crazy left axis the Sonic Fang whips a
lot there
what one over the down we're going to a
final final
game oh my God what a game what a game
how does he get around this man dude so
here's the thing right so Abel has been
doing down forward for so much after
dive kicks right and it's like every
time he does it it's getting stepped
it's getting swayed it's getting
everything right it's like so much stuff
is happening but every time he does a
dive kick it feels like Noel is like
perfect yeah perfect great yeah you I
blocked it now it's my mixup even though
I'm the one on the defense I'm mixing
you up it's like that's messed up and
you know what was the craziest part we
saw the adjustment we saw the adjustment
Abel did dive kick into standing four
which is a homing attack and and it hit
and it hit him once and then the next
time he side step block and then the the
third one he did with a mid check with
the down forward four and that's when
311 came into play again I'm like bro
stop blowing up my tiny mind man this is
this is so good this is so good I mean
Noel right now is just it does not he's
like his offense is great but it's it's
easily his defensive movement has been
the most impressive and just the
utilizing the sways not necessarily
something that you know like a lot of
Steve players will like claim to use a
lot right the sways are not necessarily
like a staple part but it's easily a
staple part here in Noel's game yeah
like the timing and when he uses it is
so good he's using it
perfectly and again we're going to go
back to abandoned Temple this is it
Grand finals in the recent final final
game Wow Let's Get it let's get it Noel
with the Steve Fox Abel with the
Eliza di kick versus back ones side
steps versus homing
attacks
who is winning highes versus high
crushes W he h he hit confirmed it nice
yeah definitely lady and he's been using
that a lot too in this set the guard
break has been helping him out a
ton there it is again you he just
eliminates down forward four from a bell
takes the first round now four wall
splinting rocket launcher
there please don't rocket Noel has the
lead in the entire set and the entire
tournament oh this time mid after back
one it's not always going to be the
flicker one down
one o catches them weaving catches them
weaving I think that's the reason why
Abel has been using that move a little
bit more too try trying to catch him
stepping no what in the world man his
low Parry timing has been crazy good but
again catching the weave with the 442
side rolls the down back to the second
one's gone the second one the cops call
him oh bats out the extp Abell with no
meter no on tournament point this is
really bad for AEL yeah that might have
been the worst outcome for AEL because
he ended up losing a meter for that lost
the round and the meter oh boy oh boy
he's building it back now though he's
going to have the meter back it's
already there basically but oh boy oh
boy here we go here we go this is scary
mid low mid low mid mid nice punish got
the wallat I wall Splat
too yep don't weave nowhere you ain't
going nowhere one two throw it's good
two to one rounds Abel can he bring it
back he almost has the full meter oh man
this is close I don't I I what I don't
know nobody does Ricky Nobody Does this
is I want to I want to have some some
sort of
like I have no analysis for this this is
crazy
wo The Shield doesn't bite back to the
zoning game ex Fireball we going in
doesn't doesn't get hit by the second
one that time right oh he had it it's so
hard it's so hard to commit on that down
for it too oh he got it but he didn't
commit there but it got blocked but it
still got punished with the counter hit
back one oh God the Alba oh no three for
three to BL down JB
up for three to win your Tekken online
challenge
2021 what we had a boxing win with a
foot
stop a jumping foot stop by the way God
dude no l
congratulations made it made a player
very happy made a Steve player very
happy oh that was beautiful that was act
yeah
you made made a non Ste player happy cuz
that was incredible that was good ass T
like straight up good ass teken yeah
really well play for both players when
we saw the counter adjustments from both
sides like a bell with the standing four
after the dive kigle was working out but
Noel man he knew that that was his
adjustment then he had the counter to
the counter to the
counter o that was good that was so good
the one and the one thing the one thing
Noel never never backed down from was
those low parries either right those low
pares were consistently on time whenever
he needed a low Parry he got him and
then got the lead and stuck with it man
and the call out too cuz uh ael's was
going for so many down Jabs in a lot of
instances and at the end Noel was just
like I'm tired of these down Jabs I'mma
blow you up I'm going jump over it with
a jumping foot stop but let's take a
look here this is the South America
standing still in first place though is
going to be a bell with the 505 but Noel
not too far behind now with the 485
third is going to be with the 245 and
then fourth we have Jackson 5 with the
240 sapito with the 195 six is dojo 2
165 sha got up to 150 today congrats and
then Alonzo Gonzalez with the one 100
106 yeah so all these guys playing for
the for these standings here but man
that was just a great great set I can't
like the way the way that set played out
was
like Madness dude just just Madness man
that was sick that was such a good Grand
finals but you know honestly that was
such a fun top eight regardless you know
big shout outs to all the competitors
once again and uh it's been to blast
guys that was that was so sick I that
that was my that was my Christmas that
was my New Year's that was my birthday
man all right so if you guys want to
though to check out some more good ass
Tekken make sure to follow us online you
got the bne Esports uh channels on
Twitch and YouTube make sure you can
follow the YouTube channel to see all of
the vods from these events on there uh
you can also follow Tech on Twitch
Twitter and as well as
Facebook yes sir absolutely yeah that
that wraps it up for another great
Tekken online challenge if you guys have
been enjoying the event don't forget
tomorrow there's another one and then
next weekend there's another one make
sure to mark down the calendar thees
they're going to be going on for the
rest of the year and going into 2022 as
well for a little bit at the beginning
but yeah I think that's going to do it
for us here at the Tekken online
challenge in South America that was fun
good good stuff to everybody man has
been a treat man has been a treat but
yeah I think that's going to do it for
me and Ricky we'll catch you guys next
time here at the teken online
challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
mer
[Applause]